[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur public sénat ce matin la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication auditionne
stéphane lissner directeur général de
l'opéra de paris et martin ajdari
directeur adjoint je vous propose de
regarder ces échanges en direct et on se
retrouve après de la situation des
publics et la façon dont les publics
aussi vont pouvoir et vouloir retourner
donc au spectacle nous aurions bien sûr
préféré que cette audition porte sur le
bilan de vos six années à la tête de
l'opéra de barie mais cette audition
c'est aussi l'occasion peut-être de vous
en dire quelques mots vous quitter vos
fonctions je tiens de rappeler à mes
collègues de directeur général à la fin
de l'année nous savons à quel point cet
opéra a déjà souffert ces dernières
années des attentats de 2015 ce site
serait parmi les événements qui ont
marqué aussi la vie de la maison cesser
ces attentats les manifestations des
fichiers jaune et bien sûr les
manifestations autour de la réforme des
retraites
l'annulation supplémentaire de plus de
150 représentations depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire porte aussi
indéniablement un coup sévère à
l'établissement
donc nous aimerions en savoir un peu
plus sur la santé financière de
l'établissement qui si j'ai bien compris
vous allez nous confirmer enregistre
aujourd'hui un déficit de 45 millions
d'euros
nous aimerions aussi comprendre
l'attitude du ministère de tutelle dans
ce contexte son positionnement et puis
les perspectives pour l'avenir monsieur
à jarry sera sans doute c'est bien
placés pour nous en nous en parler
quelle stratégie envisagez vous pour
sortir de la crise pour reconquérir les
publics reconquérir bien sûr aussi les
mécènes dans les mois à venir
et puis au delà de ça monsieur lissner
nous serions très intéressé aussi que
vous puissiez partager votre expérience
du monde lyrique que vous connaissez
particulièrement bien et nous indiquer
quels sont les défis auxquels ce monde
va être confronté moi je serais très
intéressé de de le savoir nous avons
besoin temps parlementaire être
alimenter notre réflexion sur un sujet
pour nous d'extrême importance
voilà merci d'avoir écouté patiemment ce
propos liminaire nous sommes heureux
aussi de retrouver martin jarrie dans
d'autres fonctions que celles de
l'audiovisuel et des médias
nous le connaissons de longue date
bienvenue encore une fois parmi nous
donc vous laisse la parole à l'un et
l'autre pour un propos liminaire voilà
et ensuite un jeu de questions réponses
bien sûr vous avez débuté votre propos
en parlant de la situation des opéras en
général il s'avère que la situation des
opéras est un peu différente en ce qui
concerne son modèle économique
si vous voulez il ya au fond de 2,2
paramètres très distincts les opéras qui
sont financés largement par un
financement public et les opéras qui se
financent largement par l'or à part un
autofinancement quand vous prenez
l'opéra de paris qui est à peu près
financé à hauteur de 56 à 60 % suivant
les années en autofinancement il est
évident que les recettes vont jouer un
rôle déterminant
et lorsque vous avez un opéra qui est à
60 ou 70% de financements publics le
fait qu' il arrête son activité ne va
pas énormément lui créer de problèmes
économiques
donc ça c'est là
la différence si vous regardez là si
vous regardez l'opéra de paris si on
regardait coven garden si vous regardez
la scala de milan si vous regardez le
metropolitan opera
ce sont des institutions qui vont être
dans des difficultés extrêmes
si vous regardez les opéras de plus
petite taille et dont le financement
public est largement supérieur aux
recettes propres
évidemment ces établissements ne
connaîtront ne connaîtront pas les mêmes
difficultés économiques
alors en ce qui concerne l'opéra de
paris
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
situation où le financement public
maintenant est largement inférieur à 50%
et dont je dirais le premier problème
pour moi qui se pose pour aujourd'hui
mais pour le futur dans le cadre du
modèle économique c'est que pendant des
années le financement public a couvert
le coût du personnel donc a couvert les
frais fixes
aujourd'hui le 1er janvier
dimanche environ entre 30 et 35 millions
d'euros pour arriver à couvrir le le
montant des salaires qui représente à
peu près 100 millions d'euros sur un
budget de 230 millions d'euros
ajoutez à ça évidemment les recettes de
mécénat les recettes des visites garnier
etc etc
mais on voit bien que on voit bien que
le modèle économique aujourd'hui ne peut
pas supporter soit des crises sociales
que nous avons eues vous avez parlé
alors qu'arrive crise qui était lié par
ken pas une crise sociale bien sûr
qu'ils étaient liés aux attentats mais
il ya eu ensuite effectivement les
les grèves liées à la loi elle comme riz
a eu ensuite les week-ends des gilets
jaunes mais on pourrait ajouter par
exemple les grèves de la sncf je ne
parle pas des dernières grèves monsieur
par des grèves qui ont précédé dans
lequel on avait des gros problème de
remplissage le week-end puisque la sncf
les gens ne venaient plus ne venaient
plus de province puis il ya eu
effectivement la réforme des retraites
ou là on a subi un choc très violent je
dirais d'abord au mois de décembre on
pouvait voilà je veux donner un avis
personnel on pouvait éventuellement
comprendre une réaction forte de
l'ensemble des syndicats et du personnel
puisque au fond on suspendait une caisse
de retraite qui existait depuis 350 ans
et au fond je pense que l'état n'a pas
été au rendez-vous en proposant un
projet alternatif à cette substitution à
cette annulation de cette caisse par
contre on a eu plus de mal nous comme
dirigeant à comprendre que les grèves
ont pu continuer ensuite au mois de
janvier alors que l'ensemble du pays
7 cf ratp reprenaient leurs cours tout
ça pour dire que cette période a été
très difficile
et au moment où il restait encore non
plus une grève
une graine et grèves perlées qu'il est
qui qui a repris à partir du mois de
février 15 février 20 février nous
sommes retrouvés dans le vide donc c'est
certain que là haut depuis le 5 décembre
où vit une période très grave qui a créé
des déficits importants sur l'année 2019
d'autant plus dommageable que le 5
décembre nous avions une année 2009
exceptionnelle on était même en avance
sur tous les surtout le
résultat puisqu'on était environ à plus
de 4 4,5 millions pratiquement de
résultats positifs
et puis nous avons perdu en entre le 5
décembre et le 31 décembre 2019
environ 15 à 16 millions d'euros ce qui
fait que en gros on a fini avec un
déficit de 2 millions d'euros pour
l'année 2019
et puis on est reparti à partir de 2020
avec les la continuité des grèves vente
jusqu'au jusqu'au 24 janvier pour être
précis là on a perdu de nouveau environ
5 millions d'euros et puis ensuite on
est rentré dans le dans la pandémie
voilà donc première réponse la situation
de l'opéra de paris comme institution
avec des recettes propres d'environ 60%
sont me bell aujourd'hui ne peut pas
supporter et ne supportera pas dans le
futur des crises sociales ou une crise
sanitaire comme on vient de le connaître
je j'ajouterai que au niveau de
l'organisation avant mon arrivée et
aussi à travers la gestion que j'ai fait
on va partir de 2014 il y a eu environ
110 postes entre 110 et 115 postes
exactement qui ont été supprimés dans
les dix dernières années ce qui nous
amène à 1480 postes fixes et environ 300
postes à durée déterminée je me trompe
pas donc 1480 à durée indéterminée
environ 300 intermittents plutôt moins
on pourra comparer effectif si vous ne
voulez avec les autres grands
établissements internationaux et on
verra que l'opéra de paris se défend
très bien de ce point de vue là au
niveau de sa gestion
car je rappelle on a tendance parfois
l'oublier que nous avons deux théâtres
un théâtre de 2700 places et un terrain
de 2000 places une école de danse à
nanterre et des ateliers à berthier donc
ça ça pose cette question
ça pose la question du modèle économique
et de l'engagement de l'état
je crois que
le l'établissement a fait beaucoup
d'efforts dans les dernières années les
financements publics ont baissé de
l'ordre de 10 à 15 millions d'euros
la subvention ça dépend à partir de
quand on prend cette diminution mais en
gros il ya à peu près 10 12 ans on était
à 107 108 millions d'euros et
aujourd'hui on est à 90 est donc il ya
une baisse sensible je rappelle juste un
chiffre qu'il faut connaître c'est qu'il
ya une augmentation mécanique du fait de
deux
de l'ancienneté et que chaque année
avant de parler de haine à eau
on est impérieux de 60 % d'augmentation
de salaire quoi qu'il arrive donc si
vous baissez les subventions et que
votre vos frais fixes augmentent chaque
année d'environ 1,6 merci monsieur 1,6
d'augmentation vous ajoutez à ça des
mesures nouvelles
l'inévitable vous êtes autour de 2,2
pour cent par an donc d'augmentation des
coûts et et une subvention en diminution
ou qui stagnent les courbes se croisent
ça c'est pour disons parler du modèle
après il ya pour toute autre question
mais je pense que vas tu veux ajouter
quelque chose martin sur la jarrie suite
ce sera ce sera très bref puisque
l'essentiel a été dit mais donc l'année
2020 qui est en cours pour faire l'état
des lieux
ça reste malheureusement est
principalement des constats budgétaire
mais on a effectivement dû annuler tous
les spectacles du début mars jusqu'à la
fin de la saison en juillet puis par
ailleurs face aux incertitudes de la de
la rue de la rentrée anticipée des
travaux prévue l'an prochain en 2021
pour qu'ils aient lieu cette année
plutôt que de recommencer dès le début
septembre avec une doute assez important
sur la capacité à accueillir
correctement le public
ça a conduit à une émulation presque
complète de
de tous les spectacles entre entre mars
et la fin novembre
à bastille et la fin de l'année 2021
2020 à garnier et ça se traduit
évidemment comme l'a expliqué stéphane
lissner comme on a besoin de jouer pour
ouvrir des trucs fixe contrairement à la
plupart des théâtres qui ont une version
qui couvrent leurs traits fixe et donne
marge artistique pour financer
l'activité artistique
c'est pourquoi dans le monde du
spectacle vivant par le soudeur de marge
artistique
c'est ce qui en plus de la couverture
des frais fixes vient financer
l'artistique à l'opéra de paris il faut
jouer pour couvrir les frais les
préfixes donc là on a toute une année où
on ne joue pas ou quasiment pas jusqu'à
la fin de l'année et donc on va
effectivement finir l'année 2020 avec
une perte de l'ordre de 40 milles de 40
millions d'euros l'essentiel 45 millions
d'euros dont 45 millions d'euros donc
l'essentiel est liée au co lead il ya 5
millions qui sont liées aux grèves de
janvier 40 millions liés aux qu'ovide
l'établissement avait à la fin de
l'année 2019 un fonds de roulement des
réserves en quelque sorte qu'ils peuvent
lui permettre d'investir on a de gros
besoins d'investissement dans l'outil de
production dans le bâtiment dans les
aspects patrimoniaux du bâtiment pour
les années à venir les la vingtaine
trentaine de millions d'euros de
réserves que l'établissement disposait
encore à la fin de l'année 2019 seront
négatives ils passeront passeront à
moins 20 millions d'euros à la fin de
l'année 2020 il s'est évidemment une
perspective assez angoissante parce que
l'absence de réserves ça ne pas savoir
si on pourra effectivement maintenir
correctement l'outil de travail
l'outil de production et sa sécurité et
c'est par ailleurs aussi une
une contrainte par rapport à toute prise
de risque toute innovation encore une
fois comme on est un modèle économique
qui dépend de plus en plus des recettes
commerciales trail si on n'a pas des
réserves ou le roulement qui permet de
faire face à des aléas y compris
commerciaux la tentation va être de
prendre de moins en moins de risques et
donc quelque part de d'affadir le lien
entre l'opéra de paris et la création or
ce qui est un des éléments fondamentaux
de l'opéra paris c'est qu'il ya un
répertoire il ya des oeuvres qui sont
qui attire un public large qu'il faut
renouveler mais qui ont un succès à peu
prêt garanti il ya aussi des prises de
risque de la création c'est stéphane
lissner on a produit quelques quelques
exemples particulièrement emblématiques
mosys aaron les indes galantes qui ont
permis de faire une incursion des deux
de la culture urbaine dans le dans la
musique baroque et ça ce sont des prises
de risques qui ne sont plus possibles si
on n'a pas de si on n'a pas un minimum
de réserves pour faire face aux aléas
j'ajouterai peut-être de mots 1-1 de
constat et de comparaison effectivement
on a
une subvention valeur absolue qui est
très importante 95 millions d'euros mais
elle a baissé 15 millions d'euros au
total en dix ans si on lit avant que
l'inflation s'est quasiment 25% de
baisse de l'inflation
on a en face dans le spectacle vivant
général ce qu'on appelle la loi de
baumohl n'y a pas de rendement croissant
il n'y a pas de gain de productivité ce
qui fait que le ballet la progression
des charges salariales un impact sur le
coût des théâtres ça c'est pas propre à
l'opéra mais c'est vrai de tous de
toutes les activités de spectacles
vivants et donc on a un effet de ciseaux
une tension qui se crée entre
l'évolution des recettes et l'évolution
des charges
l'évolution des recettes depuis dix ans
elle a pu être porté par une rose de la
billetterie qui atteint des niveaux
comme extrêmement important aujourd'hui
et du mécénat et on voit que ces deux
ces deux leviers la billetterie des
places qui atteignent souvent 200 euros
parfois plus parfois un peu moins une
soeur taux limite que peuvent que
peuvent assumer les spectateurs
particulièrement dans une phase où on
aura moins de spectateurs internationaux
où les sprinteurs ont un pouvoir d'achat
qui va être plus plus attention en tout
cas plus d'hésitation à aller vers ce
type de dépenses et du point de vue du
mécénat stéphane lissner a doublé le
mécénat depuis 2014 c'est un triplement
depuis 2002 puis 2005
là aussi le mécénat atteint ses limites
parce que le contexte fiscal le cadre
fiscal a été plutôt resserrées récemment
dans la loi de finances pour 2020 parce
que une bonne partie des entreprises
mécènes notamment les entreprises
moyennes hésité là on voit à peu près un
tiers de recettes de mécénat qui vont
qui vont diminuer en 2000 en 2020
hésitent à investir à un moment où elles
doivent demander des efforts et des
sacrifices alors salarié donc si on a
des grands partenaires historiques qui
restent fidèles
mais tout un ensemble de donuts de
donateurs de deux mécènes intermédiaires
qui eux ont tendance à se replier donc
on pourra pas tabler sur ses recettes là
de manière générale dans un contexte où
nous étions avant la crise et a fortiori
depuis la crise cette problématique
d'absence de fonds de roulement négatif
de 2 perte de toutes nos réserves
on a une trésorerie qui reste légèrement
positif parce que le spectateur paye le
billet à l'avancé pour une part il ya
une situation excédentaire de trésorerie
mais c'est de plus en plus de plus en
plus ténue on a eu à ce stade comme
comme établissement public et comme la
plupart des établissements publics aucun
soutien de l'état en 2020 mais parce que
l'état a considéré ce qui peut ce qui
peut s'entendre qu' il fallait commencer
par soutenir les structures privées dont
l'existence était directement menacés
les établissements publics ayant une
forme de garantie implicite
donc ça ça peut ça peut s'entendre
pendant quelques semaines quelques mois
mais à un moment ou un autre il faut
qu'on sable noir a et donc comment on va
reconstituer nos réserves
comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
fonctionner en 2021 avec un niveau de
recettes propres qui va forcément être
affectée par une crise et qu une crise
sanitaire et économique qui est pas
uniquement sanitaire qui est aussi
économique et on ne connaît pas
ni l'ampleur ni la durée de ces deux
crises d'ailleurs donc c'est cette une
des doubles difficultés auxquelles
auquel on va être confronté dès dès
l'année prochaine
un point important qui a été volé par
martin pour préciser pour préciser la
lah pour préciser la question liée aux
investissements
nous avons en une demande en moyenne je
parle de demande tout à fait raisonnable
de l'ensemble des services liés
essentiellement à la sécurité mais lié
aussi bien sûr à l'entretien des
bâtiments
nous avons une demande environ qui
tourne autour de 20 à 22 millions par an
nous arbitrons finalement et nous
tournons à la fin sur un résultat autour
de 10 à 12 millions d'euros
pour votre information l'état nous donne
un million et demi d'euros par an donc
il est évident que cet argent là il faut
le prendre sur mon résultat soit à
travers la caf soit à travers le fonds
de roulement si les résultats
donc vous comprenez bien qu'en 2019 et
en 2020 ces questions d'investissement
et qui porte beaucoup sur la sécurité
donc sans les sons les travaux
nécessaires voilà l'état et pas financer
avant à hauteur de 6 millions d'euros il
ya quelques années et aujourd'hui le
financement est de un million et demi
d'euros donc c'est un un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet parce que ces
investissements
ils sont ils sont nécessaires chaque
année et donc
par exemple parler à juste titre de la
question de la création et de la
question du répertoire comme vous le
savez l'opéra c'est à peu près 15 titres
qui se vendent très bien et ensuite il
faut créer autour des autres titres d'un
événement à soi à travers la qualité des
artistes soit à travers la qualité des
biens sur du chef des chanteurs ou des
metteurs en scène soit la découverte en
espérant que cette découverte va
intéresser public mais il faut pas se
leurrer le répertoire de l'opéra c'est
75 titres et dans ses 75 à 80 titres
vous avez à peu près 15 titres qui se
vendent vraiment bien et encore et
encore parce que comme vous les reprenez
régulièrement vous épuisez aussi le
public et en france on l'est beaucoup
plus intéressés par le théâtre la
théâtralité à l'opéra que par les voies
ce qui fait que quand vous reprenez une
traviata que vous avez fait quatre cinq
fois à vienne ou à munich et bien le
public est très intéressé de découvrir
la nouvelle violetta qui va chanter
drôle
en france on entend des écoutes et en
asie a vu le spectacle et ça c'est aussi
un problème culturel qu'il faut savoir
est que en france effectivement ça me va
vraiment on peut dire pays musicale et
donc le théâtre a pris le pas vraiment
sur la musique par rapport à la
perception que le public a aujourd'hui
de la représentation
ce qui pose un problème du répertoire
car vous imaginez bien imaginez bien que
si un barbier de séville ou une traviata
vous pouvez le jouer pendant 25 à 30 ans
à berlin
ici vous le jouez pendant 7 8 10 ans
maximum c'est à dire une fois que vous
l'avez fait quatre ou cinq fois c'est
terminé
alors que si vous regardez à londres si
vous regardez aux états unis au
metropolitan opera 11 ou la bohème de
zeffirelli de 1962 donc voyez bien que
là il ya en france cette question là ça
vient du fait que nous sommes un pays
bien plus théâtral que musical et puis
ça vient aussi du fait je le dis juste
en passant avec un peu d'humour que la
presse qui reproche souvent la
théâtralité à l'opéra si vous regardez
les articles des journalistes du tout
les journalistes vous verrez qu'ils
parlent 80% la mise en scène et à la fin
un petit peu des chanteurs et du chef
d'orchestre que ce qui nous est reproché
finalement quand le théâtre prend trop
de place et bien c'est justement ce que
la presse régulièrement défend donc si
vous devez vous entraîner le public à
travers l'idée de la théâtralité on dit
plus long diplo on dit pas le don
giovanni de mozart ou dit le don
giovanni de haneke
donc vous voyez bien on attend le même
le titre est accolé le nom du metteur en
scène lui-même a collé au titre donc
c'est une question importante parce que
ça renvoie à l'économie de la maison et
ça renvoie la question du répertoire et
c'est pour ça que c'est très compliqué
aussi de créer un répertoire durable
dont une maison comme celle là et vous
imaginez bien que faire une nouvelle
production ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
évidemment que de reprendre une
production existante c'est cesser les
chiffres qui sont pas comparables
quand vous avez une production je vous
donne un exemple très rapide quand vous
avez une production comme le var bcbe
que vous reprenez vous pouvez espérer
sans aucune difficulté à faire
pratiquement 150000 à 200000 euros de
bénéfice à l'opéra bastille et pour vous
faites une nouvelle création du barbier
de séville bla vous avez plus ou moins
équilibrés le nombre de représentations
donc sur des séries de dix douze
représentations vous allez avoir un gain
de 2 voire 3 millions d'euros sur une
reprise et vous allez avoir plus ou
moins un peu plus que les qui dit mais
en tout cas pas ces chiffres là donc qui
dit remplacement du répertoire dit
dépenses supplémentaires
et qui dit spectacle
repris trop souvent est bien petit à
petit le public
diminue et donc les résultats
économiques s'ensuivent c'est une
question importante nous sommes dans un
pays dans lequel le public est attirée
avant tout par le spectacle merci pour
toutes ces précisions
quelques mois donc je donne la parole à
mes collègues et pour rebondir sur ce
qu'elle dit martin ajdari notre
commission s'est beaucoup mobilisée sur
l'équité des aides apportées à tout type
de structure en période de crise je
pense aux mesures de chômage à temps
partiel par exemple craint pas aux
établissements publics j'ai encore écrit
à leur usine bachelot en fin de semaine
dernière je lui redis oralement que
c'est pas tenable c'est pas tenable il
ya beaucoup de maisons en france d'opéra
qui fonctionnent comme des
établissements de coopération culturelle
qui vont se trouver dans les plus
grandes difficultés dans les semaines à
venir voilà alors je donne ma parole
sylvie robert pour un premier volet de
questions jeudi lui merci beaucoup
madame la présidente merci à vous pour
ses propos mais qu'ils sont mais
finalement n'est pas si surpris que ça
très préoccupant et même vertigineux
dans la perspective et la prospective
que vous nous dessiner le groupe de
travail que j'ai animée avec un certain
nombre de mes collègues qui sont ici
présents à a notamment
[Musique]
révélé un manque de visibilité à ces
taux de la part de l'état pur je dirais
commencé à accompagner les acteurs sur
la reprise de la saison et vous nous
dites vous même que vous allez reprendre
et on a bien compris ce qu'on dit
maintenant dans un mode dégradé c'est à
dire pas dans les conditions normales
forcément et même en décalage avec
apparemment mois de novembre pour
bastille et fin de l'année pour tous
berthier pour garnier est ce que vous
auriez est ce que vous attendez encore
des clarifications un peu sur ces sur 7
sur cette rentrée un accompagnement en
termes de visibilité d'acompte pas de
précision ou est ce que comme comment
avez vous pris ses décisions
est-ce que c'est eu égard bien sûr au
modèle économique et à tout ce que vous
nous avez bien sûr des cris et puis
finalement ça révèle aussi le mode de
fonctionnement de l'art lyrique de
l'opéra avec les répétitions le temps
tout ce que vous avez dit terme de
répertoire est ce que pour autant des
répétitions ont lieu dans dans les
salles est ce que vous avez commencé à
finalement quand même enclenché une
activité sans public est pour vous
comment allez vous retrouver cette
confiance
dans le public avez-vous déjà des voilà
des idées pour que ils reprennent
confiance pour revenir dans vos salles
la deuxième chose mais vous l'avez dit
donc je ne m'étendrai pas c'est la
question du mécénat
on avait déjà mesuré un que ça allait
être en cascade et forcément que ça
allait avoir des conséquences
préoccupantes et et alain autres
collègues il reviendra peut-être mais on
voit bien que la question du mécénat et
notamment sur des modèles économiques
comme le vôtre va peser et et bien sûr
et est encore un sujet de préoccupation
alors est ce que par exemple sur la
question des du prix des places vous
allez faire quelque chose
comment mais je comprends en même temps
à la difficulté de mes modèles
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
si vous avez déjà commencé a finalement
élaborer une stratégie à la fois une
stratégie en terme de modèle économique
un peu différent mais aussi une
stratégie envers envers les publics et
enfin vous nous avez parlé donc
l'anticipation des investissements
notamment sur les projets d'entretien et
de mise aux normes des deux décident de
garnier 2 et de bastille la salle
modulable ou est-ce que vous en êtes
est ce qu'elle est encore d'actualité et
je pense que sur le site de batz style
vous deviez contribuer à hauteur d'un
quelques millions d'euros pour la salle
modulable pour la salle modulable et
millions d'euros 10 millions qu'en est
il aujourd'hui
mais gare à ce que vous nous avez dit je
ne sais pas mais voilà trois questions
assez simple mais qui en tout cas
nous intéresse beaucoup parce qu on
mesure l'ampleur l'ampleur des
conséquences de cette crise et sur les
maisons d'opéra et l'art lyrique
on a tous moi je suis à rennes c'est un
tout petit opéra mais en même temps on
voit bien que à la fois le modèle
économique est aussi le mode de
fonctionnement de de votre discipline
induit peut-être des réflexions de fond
et structurelles pour demain
je suis venu à rennes voire inondations
il ya pas très longtemps et c'était un
très beau spectacle
oui alors non la prob
mark martin je pense répondre ah si tu
veux bien sûr la salle modulable quelque
chose un peu un peu complexe et la peau
difficultés encore à comprendre bien ce
qui va se passer mais martin l'aïd
non je vais répondre à la première
question au niveau de la stratégie
j'ai proposé à l'état de rendre à
anticiper des travaux savait que les
travaux étaient prévus à l'été 2000 21
étaient 2021 ça correspondait par
rapport à la programmation à mon départ
et à l'arrivée de mon successeur
et donc j'ai estimé qu'avec les
incertitudes qui pesait sur compte tenu
de la crise sanitaire
j'ai estimé que c'était absolument plus
l'intelligent de faire ces travaux
maintenant
ne sachant pas comment on allait
recevoir le public à partir du mois de
septembre octobre novembre et je crois
malheureusement que j'ai eu raison
d'anticiper parce que c'est pas certain
qu'on va pouvoir les recevoir comme
justement on peut espérer les recevoir
en 2021
et donc j'ai considéré que s'il valait
mieux faire les travaux maintenant
plutôt que de refermer de nouveau et
d'arrêter la machine de nouveau dans 21
pour quatre mois au moment où arrive mon
successeur et où il a besoin au
contraire d'avoir les meilleures
conditions pour comment fait fondre son
mandat donc finalement ça c'était le
premier point important
on a mis pas mal de temps avoir la
réponse mais nous lâche vraiment fini
par l'avoir a perdu un peu de temps je
crois que ça va même durer entre cinq et
six semaines pendant la réponse donc on
a perdu un peu de temps et le temps pour
nous en ce moment c'était assez
important parce que ça
décalé le travail de programmation
alternative que je voulais mettre en
place à partir de septembre à garnier en
considérant que nous faisions les
travaux du cintre et que en fermant le
rideau de fer nous pourrions en relevant
la fosse d'orchestre avoir une
programmation de concerts et une
programmation de balai ce qui fait que
garnier ne sera pas fermée garnier à
partir du 19 septembre fera tous les
week-ends enfin presque tous les
week-ends des concerts et y aura vingt
représentations d'un ballet classique à
partir du 4 octobre et il y aura ensuite
vingt représentations d'une soirée et
contemporaine avec le ballet ce qui fait
qu'il y aura quand même une activité
régulière avec des concerts de musique
de chambre jusqu'à la petite messe
solennelle de rossini ou le requiem de
fauré et c'est donc avec le choeur
également donc ça c'était une
programmation alternative
on l'a mis en place on va l'annoncer
dans les jours qui viennent et elle est
allée maintenant prête
et puis à bastille par contre comme vous
l'avez dit justement là on ne peut rien
faire donc on doit redémarrer à partir
du 23 novembre
on va faire un cycle de la tétralogie et
on est fait avec martin de faire le
deuxième cycle à radio france pourquoi
parce qu'en faisant deux cycles en
version concert ça va obliger à
supprimer beaucoup de représentation de
la bayadère 2 carmen et de traviata
qu'on espère jouer et moi je dois
veiller à un équilibre pour que tout le
monde puisse revenir et donc il faut
aussi que les danseurs étoiles puissent
danser que le corps de ballet travail
que le choeur chante dans traviata cas
comme vous le savez à part le crépuscule
des dieux dans la tétralogie le coeur ne
chantent pas et donc tout ça j'ai essayé
d'avoir un équilibre donc face et la
stratégie au niveau de la de dison de de
maintenant jusqu'à la fin de l'année
en considérant qu'à partir de janvier
les deux théâtres serait normalement en
conditions normales et donc à partir de
l'été prochain ce qui permettra
d'ailleurs à mon successeur également de
prolonger la saison que j'avais fini le
30 juin pour débuter des travaux et je
fait qu'il est en train de travailler
pour prolonger maintenant la saison sur
le mois de juillet parce que
ce qui dit ballet et ses terrasses et
aussi financièrement intéressant de
prolonger la saison
ça c'est la stratégie dillon général
travaux reprise ensuite dans quelles
conditions ça va se passer
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour nous de
répondre à cette question hier nous
avons fait deux concerts à garnier nous
avons fait avant-hier soir un concert
pour les abonnés les mécènes et hier
soir pour le personnel soignant et pour
un certain nombre secours catholique
samu social croix rouge et ses concerts
traditionnels gratuit du 14 juillet on
avait à peu près 1000 personnes dans la
salle en respectant les règles
sanitaires c'est à dire que un groupe un
couple peut être deux ensuite il ya une
classe externe donc on arrive à peu près
à une demie salles aujourd'hui on avait
demandé aux gens de rester masqué même
si les dépôts obligatoires donc les gens
ont gardé leur mal ce que pendant toute
la représentation tout le concert on a
supprimé l'entracte de manière à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de déplacement etc
et ça ça va poser un problème pour la
suite parce qu'on ne peut pas faire
traviata sans entracte là on a un autre
problème qui va se poser à la rentrée un
l'opéra ne peut pas se jouer sans
entracte
donc ça c'est déjà un sujet ensuite dans
les est barrière aujourd'hui le coeur ne
peut pas fonctionner sur la scène et les
danseurs non plus par définition un même
si on a vu au concert de paris hier soir
le baiser volé de presse locale ils
étaient deux
ils peuvent éventuellement se mettre
l'un près de l'autre mais on pourra pas
le faire au niveau du corps de ballet on
pourra pas le faire au niveau de tout
coeur
donc ça pose un autre problème si on
nous sommes obligés de respecter sur la
scène les gestes barrière avec 105
choristes et c'est sans parler de la
fosse d'orchestre qui pose un problème
on pourrait aller jusqu'à une
nomenclature on va dire mozartienne
c'est à dire 45 à 60 musiciens mais on
peut pas faire une tétralogie avec 120
musiciens donc il faut faire mettre
l'orchestré sur le plateau avec la
distanciation tels que nous avons fait
donc là on navigue un peu à vue parce
qu'on ne sait pas exactement ce qui va
se passer alors on a préparé tout ça on
espère que le 23 novembre fera en
condition de jouer dans quelles
conditions
comment on peut faire même un bilan prix
premier le prévisionnel
c'est très compliqué après vous avez
parlé de plein de questions que vous
avez donné vous avez parlé du prix des
places
moi je suis comme vous je suis convaincu
que le prix des places est déjà un
problème parce que nous nous racontons
pas d'histoires dès qu'on sort de
nouveau dans ce fameux répertoire des
oeuvres les plus célèbres
nous avons beaucoup de mal à vendre la
première que je vous donnais un chiffre
assez frappant il ya quinze ans à peu
près le directeur était gérard mortier
et il y avait à peu près de mémoire
entre 27 et 30 millions de billetterie
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 77 millions
c'est à dire que nous avons plus que
doublé dans les dernières années
la billetterie et nous avons plus que
doublé le mécénat puisque nous sommes
passés en gros de 8,9 millions à 19
millions cette année
et là se pose le problème de la la de la
nouvelle loi car vous le savez que on a
abaissé de 60 à 40 % face je pense que
vous connaissez ça mieux que moi donc
c'est une question en plus on a limité
évidemment je suis ensuite le montant de
ce mécénat donc nous on va être impactée
alors on va pas être impactés avec les
grandes à ce que les grandes sociétés
soit parce qu'elles sont étrangères
comme rolex par exemple qui lui n'est
pas impacté soit parce que ces grandes
entreprises soutiennent l'opéra mais ce
qui va poser des problèmes ça va être
pour les petites entreprises
et là je pense qu'on a déjà des airs les
retours qui sont pas très bons ensuite
au niveau d'autres images il faut pas se
raconter d'histoires on a aussi à
récupérer le public à travers les grèves
de décembre et de janvier qui ont
énormément choqué une partie du public
une partie des abonnés et celle ces
grèves elles vont eu des conséquences
sont encore des conséquences et nous
avons des réactions et nous avons des
réactions de mécènes ou d'abonnés qui
sont extrêmement fâchées de ce qui s'est
passé et là on a à récupérer cela donc
tout ça
ça ça doit nous inspirer pour alors la
rentrée les prix sont fixés puisque on a
vendu des abonnements donc on peut pas
changer on peut pas revenir en arrière
sur la saison 20 21 tout est vendu
enfin tout est vendu tout ce que nous
avons pu vendre avant le col vide a été
vendue et on a aussi de ce point de vue
là une baisse de 35% je crois de
d'abonnement et de 1,35
c'est sarah quart des saints car on est
entre 35% et 40% de perte de dab
d'abonnement pour la saison 20 21
est-ce qu'on va la récupérer moi je
pense que c'est peu probable
aujourd'hui il va falloir que les gens
n'aient pas peur qu'ils aient envie de
revenir etc
on voit en europe en tout cas que les
retours ne sont pas très brillants un
peu partout on voit que le public et
zita hésitent à venir et que quand on
voit on entend qu'il va falloir mettre à
mal dans un endroit clos l'idée même de
l'endroit clos sa touche évidemment le
théâtre le cinéma et cetera donc je suis
pas très optimiste mois de ce point de
vue là en tout cas sur un remplissage
surtout quand on va répliquer des
représentations pendant dix ou douze
fois quand on fait la flûte enchantée
qu'on programme quinze représentations
on peut s'inquiéter de ça même si on a
démis salle on peut s'inquiéter
comment ça va se passer donc on ne peut
pas changer des primes place
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas possible parce
que les gens ont payé donc ça nous donc
7 sur cette question là comment on va
reconquérir le public
alors on a lancé les un plan d'opération
ce qui nous a pas mal aidé c'est tout ce
qui s'est passé avec le streaming parce
qu'on a eu des résultats extraordinaires
avec le avec toutes les spectacles que
nous avons mis en ligne et aussi bien
d'ailleurs avec nos opéras avec le
ballet avec les gars là et avec la
troisième celle donc on a eu la de ce
point de vue là on a été assez leader je
dois dire 2d on a eu des résultats
extraordinaires d'ailleurs pour vous
donner un chiffre on est je crois
pratiquement premier aujourd'hui on est
quasiment premier mondial en ce qui
concerne les réseaux sociaux puisqu'on a
des potes dépasser 1 million 600 mille
abonnés 1
entre twitter facebook et et je mets
toujours le troisième critère facebook
et instagram voilà merci et un stade est
toujours à l'étroit que je prie j'ai pas
très addict donc ça c'est une aussi mais
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour le poids
la caisse qu'il espérait comment on
pourrait réagir par rapport à cette
situation au niveau de la technologie au
niveau de la d'une plateforme digitale
c'est une vraie question qu'on doit se
poser parce que le streaming tout le
monde en fait et ce qui va y avoir une
autre voie possible est ce qu'il y avait
à voir une autre proposition moi je
pense que oui
et moi je pense que on va arriver à
c'est mon idée pour l'instant personne
ne l'a encore lancé moi je crois que à
côté du spectacle vivant qui sera jamais
remplacé ni à travers l'émotion ni la
qualité de ce qu'est une représentation
moi je suis convaincu qu'on va avoir à
réfléchir sur la création d'un nouvel
objet qui est peut-être pas l'opéra tel
qu'on le connaît mais dans lequel on
devra peut-être réfléchir sur au foncier
au on réfléchit on se souvient du passé
on se souvient par exemple on a tous été
marqués par la carmen de peter brook et
quand peter beau café carmen qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il a pris des extraits de
carmen avec deux pianos et il a joué sa
house d'honneur et on a dit on a au fond
c'est dit on peut aussi donner une
émotion à travers une oeuvre du grand
répertoire autrement qu'avec un
orchestre un coeur et toute l'oeuvre
alors je ne sais pas je dis ça pourquoi
est-ce que je pense que si on
s'inspirait de cette idée là on pourrait
imaginer très bien qu' il y ait des
créations à partir du répertoire
freddy création peut-être différentes
qu'une retransmission classique dans
lequel on pourrait trouver élargir aller
vers un public différent c'est une
question sur laquelle on peut ce
courrier au niveau de la stratégie ce
n'est pas à moi de de la mettre en place
sera peut-être mon successeur peut-être
il aura cette idée ou peut-être là pas
du tout donc voila moi je vous dis
simplement que dans des stratégies
il ya cette idée sur laquelle
réfléchir mais c'est sur moi j'en suis
convaincu que à cause du modèle
économique à cause de la situation qu'on
vient de vivre etc
l'opéra de paris aujourd'hui nous avons
pas parlé de la crise d'identité n'avons
pas parlé de la situation interne en
avons beaucoup de choses à dire sur
l'opéra de paris
on a parlé pour l'instant de tout ce qui
se voit de l'extérieur mais on n'a pas
parlé de tout ce que je vois ce que vous
voyons à l'intérieur il va falloir
réfléchir sur le futur parce que cette
cette pandémie nous nous enseigne de
toute façon que pour employer le terme
un peu excessive
ça ne pourra pas continuer comme ça ça
ne peut pas continuer comme ça ça j'en
suis convaincu il va falloir réfléchir
sur le modèle il va falloir réfléchir
comment affronter
je voulais juste finir encore un tout
petit mot là dessus pour vous dire que
il faut bien se rendre compte
aujourd'hui avec 1500 salariés
l'opéra de paris est très en dessous de
la moyenne européenne
je vous rappelle que nous avons un
théâtre de 2700 places un théâtre de
2007 en place avec un plateau à des plus
grands plateaux au monde et qu'à un
théâtre si vous me permettez ce cet
exemple c'est un peu comme un
appartement une maison
plus c'est gros plus ça coûte cher parce
qu'il faut l'entretenir parce qu'il faut
du personnel etc et que sur le plateau
quand vous avez un petit théâtre que
vous avez un grand théâtre n'avait pas
le même nombre de techniciens vous avez
etc etc
bon nous avons un théâtre de 2700 places
comparé à covent garden comparé à la
scala de milan comparé à l'opéra de
vienne qui est beaucoup plus grands
théâtres sont entre 1700 et 2000 places
au quinté à tête à 2700 places
si vous ajoutez maintenant le théâtre de
garnier qui à 2000 places
vous vous rendez compte que ces deux
théâtres divison par 2500 par de
division par deux ça fait 750 personnes
par théâtre parce que la mutualisation
elle n'existe pas elle existe aussi au
niveau de la direction générale mais
elle n'existe pas au niveau des
techniciens allaient veut dire vous
pouvez pas utiliser les électriciens
d'un côté vous avez d'ailleurs des gens
qui font les costumes pour la danse
garnier vous avez des gens qui font les
costumes pour l'opéra et c'est bon vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez on a mutualisé
beaucoup mais vous ne pouvez vous amuser
si vous regardez leur forme de c th y'a
pas un théâtre en europe qui a moins de
1000 salariés
y'en a pas un ni la scala de milan je
connais bien
ni coven garden etc mais le metropolitan
opera le metropolitan opera fait 211
représentations d'opéras parents ils en
font moins que nous car nous m'attendent
ça m'a plus de 200 représentations
d'opéras puisqu'on a eu deux théâtres
bon ils ont trois mille quatre cents
salariés
il faut bien comprendre que le nombre de
salariés de cette maison de ces de
l'opéra national de paris
quand on dira mais ça coûte 97 millions
alors faisons la même chose division par
deux et on verra que 50 millions d'euros
pour chacun de ses théâtres
ça semble une somme énorme 97 millions
mais alors quand on dit à bercy 10 mai
81 17 97 millions mais ces deux théâtres
et quand je me fasse jeudi mais si vous
n'avez plus les moyens d'entretenir de
théâtre ils font en entretien mais il
faut pas nous dire que 97 millions c'est
une subvention énorme pour de théâtre ce
n'est pas vrai et ça je pense que c'est
très important de le comprendre et en
nombre de personnel parce qu'on a
attaqué beaucoup sur le nombre de
salariés de ces deux sets de cet
établissement
j'ajouterai à ses 1500 salariés dont je
me parler s'ajouteraient d'écoles de
danse je vous rappelle que nous avons
une école de danse à nanterre avec des
professeurs avec 200 élèves une école
qui est réputé dans le monde entier qui
d'ailleurs voilà parce que il faut pas
oublier que on attend de nous une grande
exigence
on attend une licence de gestion ce qui
est tout à fait normal nous on attend de
nous une exigence artistique et aussi
aussi bien pour le lyrique que pour la
danse est donc un moment donné ça coûte
et l'opéra ça coûte parce que on peut
pas supprimer le nombre de musiciens on
peut pas supprimer le nombre de balles
et je rappelle que nous avons cent
cinquante quatre musiciens pour deux
théâtres etc à bienne ils sont 160 pour
un théâtre
donc il faut bien voir ses chiffres
après on peut considérer effectivement
que c'est beaucoup d'argent que etc
oui on peut le considérer mais on nous
demande d'exploiter deux théâtres de
l'avons fait l'année dernière 500
représentations
merci vous dire ajouter quelque chose je
de trois lettres sur le modèle et sur ce
que veut dire à l'instant
stéphane lissner où on a 800 900 mille
spectateurs par ans à peu près autant
que l'ensemble de l'offre lyrique public
en france on a effectivement un budget
et une subvention est importante mais
elle représente en prit part plaçant
subventions par place 30 40 % de moins
que chaque spectateur de l'opéra comique
ou de l'opéra lyon après des modèles
différents mais il ya un effet de masse
de production d'accès du public
et encore une fois environ la moitié
voire plus la moitié des spectateurs de
spectacles lyriques chorégraphique en
france sont à l'opéra de paris tous les
ans avec une subvention qui pour le coup
et représente beaucoup moins que la
moitié de l'ensemble des subventions
publiques
ça c'est le premier élément que vous
voulez le seconde il ya effectivement
une robe grande fragilité de notre art
par rapport à la crise sanitaire que ce
soit pour les coeurs que ce soit pour
les danseurs que ce soit pour les
musiciens en france que ce soit aussi
pour les artistes qui sont souvent
qu'ils proviennent du reste du monde
dont et dont la capacité à venir répéter
ou à jouer n'est pas évidente est donc
une des difficultés particulières que
nous avons on éléments fragilité très
important c'est que on ne peut pas
interrompt pour annuler une saison à
trois mois ou à 6 mois parce que les
artistes qui répond d'un système
d'engagements internationaux sont
souvent recrutés deux trois quatre ans à
l'as vence et donc on a moins de
capacité de s'ajuster à très court terme
qu'on a à la fois des frais fixes très
important mais nos frais variables en
fait à six mois à neuf mois un nom est
parfois à deux ans ou trois ans pour les
principaux artistes lyriques on les
engage
on les recrute très longtemps à l avance
donc on a une capacité à s'ajuster à
très court terme qui est moindre cette
année les mantras j'y lis tes face à la
crise que nous avons connue ça a été
évoqué le chômage parce qu'elle est
évoquée
effectivement nous y étions
théoriquement éligibles aux termes du
décret qui a été pris dans le courant au
début du mois de mai ayant plus de 50 %
de ressources propres mais on nous a
demandé si nous voulions avoir accès au
chômage partiel à ne pas compenser un
euros de perte de rémunération pour les
salariés contrairement à ce qui a pu se
produire à la ratp à la sncf ou dans
d'autres établissements publics et au
sein de la culture et dans
l'environnement public dans la très
grande majorité des cas les salaires ont
été maintenues au-delà les rémunérations
liées à l'activité différentes primes
qui est la route est perdu et donc c'est
un choix qu'il est difficile d'imposer
aux salariés de l'opéra l'absence de
recours au chômage partiel pour une
activité industrielle et commerciale
comme celle de l'opéra de paris ça peut
représenter sur la durée d'inactivité 25
30 millions d'euros on retrouve quand
même partie de nos pertes dans cette
absence de d'accès à des conditions à
peu près à peu près satisfaisante au
chômage partiel
donc ça c'est quelques points je voulais
je voulais rappeler sûr
e effectivement ce que nous avons fait
en cette période d'inactivité
l'audiovisuel le numérique ils gagnent
toutes les semaines une éditorialisation
d'une captation audiovisuelle en
partenariat avec france télévisions ce
qui a permis d'avoir de plus de 2
millions de vues de spectacles vus sur
ses offres numériques pendant la période
du confinement ce qui est quand même
vraiment résultat assez assez
encourageant la troisième scène a connu
d un nombre de visites inédits et un
débouché aujourd'hui dans les salles de
cinéma avec une série de quatre courts
métrages qui sont proposés depuis là
depuis la semaine dernière on annonçait
la plateforme ariac est une plateforme
éducative de familiarisation avec les
univers du ballet l'opéra qui a déjà
recruté deux cent mille utilisateurs
actifs donc on a essayé de maintenir ce
lien par par le numérique ça ne remplace
pas il faut être très clair le lien qui
peut se créer ce qui peut se nouer dans
une salle évidemment mais mais c'est
important la salle modulable donc
effectivement projet qui est intimement
lié à l'aménagement de la cité berthier
pour offrir des salles des espaces de
représentation supplémentaire à la
comédie française et à l'odéon l'opéra
de paris il ya des des éléments de
stockage il dit produisait régulièrement
des répétitions de ce spectacle de
garnier et il ya par ailleurs pas mal de
des ateliers et et du stockage de toiles
de costumes qui sont situés le projet de
salle modulable et d'aménagement du site
de bastille ça consiste pour un budget
d'à peu près 60 millions d'euros qui a
été arrêté il ya deux trois ans à armées
équipées
enfin la salle modulable présente dans
le site de bastille depuis l'origine
mais qui a été laissé inexploitées non
aménagé pour des raisons de coûts à
l'époque et donc ça parlait de
parachever le projet de l'opéra bastille
et d'aménager le
différents espaces notamment ce qu'on
appelle le site des délaissés qui est un
espace aujourd'hui n'ont construit près
de l'hôpital des quinze-vingts de
l'aménager pour y construire une
extension de l'atelier de décor et
stocker ce qui est aujourd'hui à
berthier pour tout ceci est une
opération assez importante
en investissement ces supposés demain
permettre d'avoir des productions
propres notamment celle de l'académie de
l'opéra de paris également l'accueil de
production d'esthétique de de richesse
ou une densité plus diverse que ce que
l'on peut donner ce tome grande salle de
bastille et garnier
ça doit permettre aussi de faire de
location événementiel pour avoir une
source de revenus complémentaires et
d'accueillir des répétitions pour
libérer un peu de temps deux plateaux à
bastille et garnier pour consolider le
modèle économique dont tout ceci en
cours de gestation depuis six mois on a
beaucoup travaillé les architectes pour
faire rentrer le budget le projet dans
le budget parce que leurs premières
esquisses comme toujours
comme souvent malheureusement dépasser
largement le budget initial d'un bond un
bon 25% donc on a un travail assez dur
avec eux un travail aussi auquel
participent alexander nef de deux
d'affinement du projet de la salle
l'idée d'avoir une salle modulable qui
ne soit pas un théâtre à l'italienne
mais qui puisse accueillir toutes sortes
de configuration scénique qui soit
complémentaire des théâtres plus
classique dans leur forme que son que
son bastille et garnier
on attend de la part de l'état dans les
prochaines dans les prochaines semaines
hier une confirmation confirmation de ce
projet dans sa dimension dans son
calendrier
alors qu on se s'attend évidemment à ce
qu'il y ait un rabattage de cartes assez
important d'un point de vue économique
financier budgétaire vu le contexte où
nous sommes mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
ce projet continue à être
je n'irai cadré au plan financier
économique et s'assagit veille plus
particulièrement il a continué à être
affinés aussi du point de vue
fonctionnel et de son usage et de
l'esthétique de la salle pour être
vraiment complémentaires de ceux dont
l'opéra de paris dispose aujourd'hui et
je pense qu'on aura dans le courant de
l'été une décision de confirmation ou
par le cas échéant ça on attend on
attend une je dirais un signal ou un
message de la part de la part de l'état
merci monsieur atari alors monsieur
ghosn a demandé la parole ya de
plusieurs collègues qui l'ont fait et
devant la loi merci au président oui
tout d'abord remercier monsieur le
directeur général des informations
précises et relativement synthétique que
vous donnez pour avoir vraiment une
appropriation de ceux du du problème
heureux de retrouver martin ajdari que
j'ai connu au conseil d'administration
de radio france et qui nous manque
je dois le dire parce que vous
réussissiez sans faire trop long mais a
donné à la fois avec une grande culture
une connaissance une grande une grande
connaissance oui mais je ne parle que ce
que j'ai pu juger d'une grande culture
et à la fois d'un intérêt pour les
finances de l'état ce qui par les temps
qui courent présente là aussi un grand
intérêt nous partageons d'ailleurs ce
que vous avez expliqué tout à leur fort
bien puisque nous sommes des
représentants des territoires et des
collectivités territoriales nous sommes
pris dans cette tenaille entre la baisse
des recettes et la hausse des dépenses
donc nous partageons tout à fait à une
autre chaîne ce que vous avez dit ma
question et techniques et pourra vous
paraître surprenante mais ici nous
sommes dans la commission culture
communication et éducation et dans le
champ le grand champ de nos thématiques
nous avons le sport or pour bien
connaître
les représentants du corps de ballet ils
sont tout à fait assimilable à des
sportifs de haut niveau
quand on connaît et même parfois plus
que des sportifs de haut niveau dans des
thématiques
voilà quel est le suivi médical des
danseurs étoiles danseurs danseuses et
ou du corps de ballet est-ce que cela a
progressé dans le temps quand on est là
qu est la situation aujourd'hui par
rapport à leur suivi médical parce que
là on est vraiment dans quelque chose de
très pointu qui peut influer d'ailleurs
sur les représentations
voilà c'était juste la question que je
voulais avant tout d'abord le vrai
passage la vraie transformation elle a
été opérée au moment de l'arrivée de
benjamin millepied qui a fait un certain
nombre de propositions et d'ailleurs ces
propositions étaient financées par du
mécénat
pour donner un exemple qui va vous
paraître peut-être étrange il a fait
changer des parquets et en changeant les
parquets on a obtenu effectivement c'est
fait maintenant
statistiquement reconnu on a moins de
blessures donc ces nouveaux parquet où
ils ont donné une souplesse voilages et
proches pour fêter van geyte on a mis en
place un tenant de 2,2 changement
d'organisation aussi bien dans les temps
en termes de pose qu'en terme de repas
etc
parce que l'organisation du travail
n'avait pas changé depuis 1983 depuis
l'époque noureev et donc là on a repris
vraiment une nouvelle organisation
il ya des médecins qui sont venus qui
est rond qui nous ont rejoint un qui
sont payés et donc
là le moment du coc vide évidemment est
un moment très compliqué parce qu'un
danseur peut effectivement même chez lui
éventuellement avant de pouvoir revenir
parce qu'on est on est revenu assez vite
quand même à l'intérieur pour faire des
cours etc pour faire le cours du matin
mais pour un danseur il peut travailler
physiquement à la maison mais une chose
qui peut pas faire chez lui c'est qu'il
peut pas sauter et ça c'est le grand la
grande difficulté pour lui parce que
c'est là que se joue son sens un
cerf-volant l'enjeu pour lui il est là
et donc on a considéré que juste que
entre maintenant il nous fallait entre
deux mois et deux mois et demi pour
retrouver physiquement donc des
conditions normales pour pouvoir de
nouveau accomplir leur travail c'est
pour ça que les premières orientations
de balai auront lieu début début octobre
mais on est très perfectible mais c'est
vrai que depuis maintenant que je suis
arrivé en fait jamais mis les pieds à
donner vraiment à une nouvelle
orientation
nous avons nous nous sommes améliorés il
ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
mais c'est vrai pour les musiciens aussi
avec les tendinites avec tout ce qu'on a
tous convient etc
et c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles cette réforme des retraites a
posé un problème c'est c'est au fond de
la que le malaise est parti parce que
tous ces personnes qui ont effectivement
des problèmes de santé et que cette
caisse permet de résoudre par rapport à
un musicien qui a 60 ans par exemple ne
peut plus jouer parce qu'il ne peut plus
physiquement jouer le sac ça a été un
des caisses qui va nous arriver ça a été
un ça paraît simple comme on dit comme
ça mais ça a été un point de départ
merci le précise et juste madame la
présidente
merci de le préciser parce que c'est
justement un détail qui n'est pas percé
pas perçu d'ailleurs par les spectateurs
ou parle par les français dans leur
grande majorité mais qui est
particulièrement important et capital
serez vous
normalement on a augmenté énormément le
nombre de représentations à noël pour
des raisons économiques
disons les choses comme elles sont et
bien quand on fait 25 24 au 25
représentations de bayadère même si on a
plusieurs coupes des toiles le corps de
ballet y danse tous les soirs et les
corps fond on demande beaucoup et donc
ça c'est aussi des questions sur
lesquelles c'est pour ça que je suis
convaincu moi qu'il faut augmenter le
nombre de danseurs et pour pouvoir jouer
plus mais le nombre de si on parle
d'économie
eh bien on pourrait augmenter le nombre
de docteurs pour avoir plus de
représentations et je pense qu'une
augmentation par exemple de 20 danseurs
pourrait donner des résultats positifs
d'un point de vue économique et pouvoir
reposer sur certaines périodes parce que
vous rendez compte ce qui se passe entre
le 20 novembre et le 5 janvier s'est
enfin il n'y a pas un autre théâtre au
monde qui fait une série on reçoit 120
mille spectateurs pendant ce temps là et
on joue tous les jours
pardon de 2,2 petit éclairage
complémentaire le la
le médecin la professeure là mais la
médecine xavière barreau qui travaille
auprès du ballet travaille également
extrêmement activement à l'insep donc
elle est parfaitement je dire il ya un
lien direct qui est fait entre la
condition de sportifs de haut niveau des
danseurs du ballet et la danse notamment
la danse classique demande au niveau
d'exigence porté par le bais de l'opéra
de paris à un niveau extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement élevé pointe hui
c est effectivement c'est vrai pour les
danseurs comme pour les instrumentistes
on dit souvent oui mais le régime
spécial les danseurs et les musiciens
d'orchestre ailleurs en france d'or
qu'elle serait compris nationaux ou 2 ou
deux compagnies de compagnie de mon
niveau non pas ce régime c'est vrai mais
ce que vivent les artistes de l'opéra de
paris c'était un niveau d'exigence de
qualité exigés au quotidien avec un
nombre de représentations extrêmement
élevé que aucun d'entre eux ne veut
avoir le sentiment en jouant
éventuellement au delà de ses capacités
physiques que ce soit d'ailleurs plus
pour les primes tendineux des problèmes
de bouche des problèmes auditifs ne veut
se mettre en situation de d'altérer ou
de menacer la qualité et l'exigence
artistique de l'ensemble en étant
contraint ou conduit à continuer à jouer
au delà de ce que les capacités
physiques permettaient c'est pour cela
que le le régime spécial par le départ
en retraite précoce pour les danseurs la
danse classique est vraiment
extraordinaire non exigeante au rythme
et à l'intensité où elle est produite
l'opéra de paris c'est là aussi où la
capacité à partir en invalidité dans des
conditions spécifiques pour les
musiciens l'orchestré de l'opéra de
paris pour les artistes des coeurs ceci
fait partie de du projet global de sa
qualité c'est pour cela que je dirais la
remise en cause de ce régime spécial
sans qu'elles soient suffisamment
anticipé expliquer ou précédées de
mesures de substitution ou de complément
pour le remplacer le cas échéant a
provoqué une telle une telle
mobilisation faut savoir que nous avons
nous faut les danseurs il n'y a pas une
seule compagnie aujourd'hui en france
qui fait qui dit qu'il fait plus de 200
représentations plus les tournées et
tout ça donc plus c'est pour fait que on
a beaucoup la retraite et à 40 devant
mais je peux vous dire qu'à partir de 38
37 38 39 ans on a déjà on perd déjà en
route quelques danseurs et parce que
encore une fois y danse depuis l'âge de
17 18 ans dans le ballet et il danse
beaucoup et danse beaucoup plus
qu'ailleurs pour fait que martin l'a dit
à juste titre qu'on dira mais les autres
compagnies comment font-elles est les
autres compagnies donc d'abord on
n'attend pas la même exigence par nombre
de dire enfin nous sommes à des
meilleurs ballets au monde
tout le monde est unanime pour le dire
mais ça demande un travail absolument
considérable et d un niveau de ces
malheureusement pas follement qualitatif
c'est aussi quantitatif 40 joue beaucoup
merci monsieur li ser alors je dois
d'abord là monsieur ouzoulias ensuite
[Musique]
merci même la présidente
merci monsieur le directeur général pour
la clarté de votre votre propos c'est
une une marque de confiance auquel nous
sommes extrêmement sensibles quand vous
nous décrivent y est votre modèle
économique finalement on se demandait si
vous n'aviez pas à la fois les
inconvénients d'un délégataire de
service public mais sans les avantages
c'est à dire que ce qui est placé à
votre charge c'est la totalité de ce qui
est le montage des spectacles mais là où
un délégataire
à des avantage c'est que la structure
qui lui délègue prend à sa charge une
partie de l'entretien et surtout la
rénovation
alors là vous avez les deux et on
comprend bien que dans votre modèle
économique c'est absolument inconcevable
coman miss à la culture peut vous
demander cela en plus et moi j'aimerais
bien comprendre alors pour pour l'opéra
bastille - mais surtout pour gagner pour
garnier pardon
quelle est la place que prend la drac
ile de france dans la rénovation du
bâtiment qui est lui-même classés
quelle est la répartition alors j'aurai
juste une une question qui après je vous
laisse vous exprimer j'ai été très
sensible à ce que vous nous avez dit sur
la capacité du public parisien a accepté
autre chose que des spectacles avec une
mise en scène extrêmement élaboré ce qui
n'est pas le plus facile
aujourd'hui il y à d'autres d'autres
scènes en ile de france
je pense notamment à l'opéra royal de
versailles ou alors sur un répertoire
encore beaucoup plus difficile
le ski est proposé à l'année c'est
beaucoup de spectacles en version de
concert ce qui est ce qui montre qu'il
peut y avoir quand même un public pour
ce type de deux choses et la question
comme je suis aussi sénateur des
hauts-de-seine c'était pour vous
demander si la réalisation de deux
nouveaux endroits de la culture je pense
à la scène musicale a fait que vous avez
senti dans votre public des différences
et qu'il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont pu migrer vers cette
nouvelle scène de l'ouest parisien
et enfin je voulais vous souhaiter une
bonne route vers le centre carlo qui ne
savent absolument prodigieuse
dans l'architecte émis drano là je finis
par une boutade en disant que c'est un
autre cirque
voilà je vais je vais répondre je vais
répondre je vais répondre sur le premier
point je vais vous donner un exemple
c'est intéressant le ce que vous avez
dit au niveau du public privé on va dire
ça
avec les avantages et sans en avoir les
inconvénients sans en avoir les
avantages etc
je vous donne un exemple très simple
depuis que je suis arrivé je j'essaie de
convaincre la tutelle et bercy sur la
question du plafond d'emploi par exemple
nous sommes contraints chaque année vous
savez on vote à l'assemblée et c'est
tous les établissements nous sommes
contraints à un plafond d'emplois
bref ce que j'essaye d'expliquer c'est
que ce plafond d'emploi est une
contrainte pour nous qui pourrait être
remplacé par un plafond économique
je vous donne un exemple nous avons 100
millions d'euros de frais de personnel
on nous impose de ne pas dépenses de ne
pas dépasser ces 100 millions d'euros à
nous de gérer ces 100 millions d'euros
comme nous le souhaitons augmenter si
diminué ceci diminue cetc mais le
plafond d'emplois c'est un véritablement
un handicap pour nous et c'est un
handicap aussi vis-à-vis des dettes a
regagné avec les organisations
syndicales
c'est très très compliqué pour nous
c'est une contre je prenais d'exemple
donc nous avons effectivement cela
puisque nous sommes finalement coincé
entre une tutelle qui à juste titre à
des exigences fiscales finances
l'établissement et c'est tout à fait
normal et des syndicats et que
finalement on les prix entre entre cdc
ces deux pôles si je puis dire donc je
pense que le futur
hélas pas rentrer dans les détails parce
que c'est pas l'objet ou soldats réunion
mais je pense que le parler du modèle
économique mais je pense que la
gouvernance de toute façon là dessus
j'ai pas mal de réfléchi je veux pas en
parler aujourd'hui mais je pense que
l'organisation de cette maison la
gouvernance est maison devant
évolué c'est certain il ya plein d gain
dé plein d'exemples qu'on peut donner
par rapport à l'europe et par rapport à
ce qui se passe à l'europe par rapport à
la scala de milan que j'ai dirigé
pendant dix ans que je connais bien
comment ça fonctionne et comment ils
vont évoluer par rapport à aller à des
as les vraies questions économiques il
avait et plein d'autres choses
donc ça c'est un sujet notre position
n'est pas clair elle n'est pas claire
elle ne nous permet pas de gérer
véritablement comme on le voudrait
en acceptant bien sûr le contrôle j
insiste là-dessus
donc c'est une vraie question alors là
la deuxième question vous l'avez porté
sur wii non est ce que oui peut-être
maintenant ce que je vous dit peut-être
je me suis mal exprimé ce que je voulais
dire c'est pas tellement que le public
c'est pas le public qu'il est tellement
lié à aoun est une élaboration c'est que
il il
ils se lassent rapidement du même
spectacle qui est repris régulièrement
et que donc on perd très vite la
possibilité de remplir une traviata
qu'on rejoue pour la cinquième ou
sixième fois parce que le fait de
changer la distribution n'est pas assez
motivant pour le public et c'est pour ça
que très vite on est obligé de refaire
des nouvelles productions
c'est ça c'est ce que je voulais dire
peut-être que vous voulez répondre sur
la troisième question qui était le la
scène musicale bah moi je peux juste non
pardon non mais juste à favre a eu en
une seconde alors je pense que la
philharmonie la scène musicale tous ces
nouveaux établissements c'est positif
pour moi c'est pas du tout négatif
je pense que s'il ya des salles
l'important c'est qu'ils de la qualité
si à la qualité dans les tons voilà là
on voit le succès de la philharmonie moi
je pense que le succès de la
philharmonie s'éteint c'est un succès
pour paris c'est un succès pour le père
à ce succès pour la france etc
c'est positif j'y vois pas du tout
concurrence d'abord on fait du
symphonique nous on fait du eric ont
fait de la danse donc c'est qu'on n'est
pas voilà le peut-être la seule chose
c'est qu'ils sont beaucoup moins cher
que nous et ça ça m'embête parce que
j'aimerais bien les mêmes prix de places
[Musique]
madame darcos merci infiniment merci à
vous chers amis pour vos explications
extrêmement clair j'avais plusieurs
choses très différentes mais donc des
petites questions un bâton ont pu vous
n'avez pas dit si dans le répertoire de
cette année certaines choses pourraient
être prolongées ou ramener pour l'année
prochaine parce que comme vous dites les
programmations sont tellement longues à
3,4 en mai ce que vous auriez réussi à
récupérer quand même un spectacle ou
deux une question aussi très basique
très simple comment ce qu'on indemnise
en effet des solistes quand les les
spectacles sont annulés comme ça du jour
au lendemain ou canton droit carrément
annulée entièrement les représentations
quid de l'american friends parce qu'on
parlait beaucoup des du mécénat
j'ai ouï dire que les opéras aux etats
unis c'est encore plus catastrophique
que chez nous et donc est ce qu'à terme
ça voudrait pas dire qu'on aime aussi
quand les frontières vont réouvrir
ekoloko vite ce sera derrière nous on
pourra récupérer peut-être aussi un peu
plus de plus de ce public américain à
ces férus d'abord de pelles de balai
mais aussi d'aupérin parce que je crois
que là bas ça va être
peut-être irréparable en tout cas dans
certains opéras que vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi
est-ce que je peux me permettre de vous
demander où on en est même si une
captation vidéo mais des retraites
concernant vos différents sera de
salariés et de vos négociations est ce
qu'elles sont complètement terminés ou
est ce comme on le sujet va être mis sur
la table par le gouvernement il risque
enfin et vous avez encore pas forcément
avec les danseurs mais avec certains
certains secteurs en fait activités vous
avez encore à achopper sur quelques
quelques sujets vous avez parlé en effet
monsieur lissner de deux autres se
renouveler en opéra est ce que vous avez
eu un retour en terme d'audience or
c'est très compliqué par internet mais
des captations télévisés et notamment
manon on a manqué bien évidemment
c'était le désastre de notre vie de
notre de notre année et on a pu le
regarder bien évidemment sur internet
mais vous avez fait beaucoup de
captation donc ça serait intéressant de
savoir et c'est vrai que manger ça faire
plaisir à ma copine suivi ma maman
habite pleurtuit près de pleurtuit et
elle va au cinéma voir tous les opéras
qui passe au cinéma il y en a de plus en
plus ça se sait moins mais c'est vrai
que dans la façon de se réinventer
c'est déjà en tout cas une façon qui a
fait ses preuves est ce qu'il ya des
incidences financières par rapport à vos
pertes actuelles sur l'école de danse
parce que tu en avais parlé mais est ce
que en plus de l'éducation nationale est
ce qu'il y avait quelque chose et pour
la promotion des danseurs puisqu'on sait
que maintenant c'est maintenant depuis
plusieurs années il ya eu tous ces
blocages et donc on sait qu'on a besoin
de faire passer des nouvelles étoiles et
deux nouveaux maîtres promotion est ce
que dans ces cas là ça reste bloqué et
donc est ce que ça pose un problème pour
les promotions à venir
et puis dernière question voyez c'est
une rafale de choses la matinée rêve
d'enfant qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur 30 plus de trente ans d'existence
de dix mois d'école et d'opéra
comment bah oui mais justement mais du
coup simplement j'imagine que ça n'a pas
eu lieu cette année enfin je sais pas
comment est ce que les classes qui
s'était préparé pour ceux qui ne le
savent pas dans mes collègues
c'est donc dès des classes qui prennent
qui décide de s'engager pour voir tous
les secteurs tous les métiers de l'opéra
et il ya un spectacle extraordinaire au
mois de décembre
donc je ne sais pas si celui là aura
lieu en décembre et surtout comment ça
s'est passé pendant cette année
particulièrement mais depuis deux trois
ans en effet chaotique voilà merci
impossible pour alexandre dernier mon
successeur de reprendre des spectacles
de cette année qui ont été annulés pour
la saison 21 22 parce que sa
programmation est faite quasiment il
peut peut-être module est un peu mais
pas beaucoup de choses
par contre je crois savoir et martin le
confirmera qu'il ya des spectacles
effectivement qui vont être reportées en
22 23 ou en 23 24 voix la vidéo comme
vous le savez les programmations sont
fait pratiquement 3 à 4 ans elle avance
donc c'est toujours un peu mais il reste
toujours des trous donc je pense que ça
fera sera possible de répondre à la
dernière question est-ce que vous avez
touché là malheureusement un sujet pour
moi qui a été très très sérieux et très
très grave qui est l'histoire de rêve
d'enfant je vous réponde avec beaucoup
de franchise comme d'habitude mais voilà
le rêve d'enfant c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis longtemps ça se passe en
général vers l'ol et c'est une
représentation en matinée que nous
donnons pour les enfants défavorisés des
banlieues financé par les mécènes de la
robe qui financent ça donc on attend de
1700 enfants qui viennent et qui assiste
toujours un ballet classique à bastille
est allé l'année dernière donc en 2019
nous avions comme vous le savez donc
cette crise liée à la réforme des
retraites mais bon parce qu'on avait
tous considéré que cet après midi là
était un peu particulière puisqu'il
s'agit encore une fois d'une orientation
très ciblé et malheureusement donc les
enfants sont venus il ya eu ce brunch
ont fait 1 brawn sont les dans l'est
dans les espaces de bastide assez
émouvant parce que c'est vraiment des
enfants qui ne sont jamais allés au
terrain et c est malheureusement les
syndicats ont décidé en fin de matinée
de faire la grève et donc il n'y a pas
eu de représentation voilà donc ça a été
un choc
en ce qui me concerne et un petit peu un
vrai choc dois vous l'avouer
parce que je suis habitué à des
négociations je suis habitué à beaucoup
de choses mais là je trouve que on avait
un petit peu dépassé les bornes pour ne
pas dire plus et au plus en plus à
beaucoup beaucoup perturbé les mécènes 1
parce que il ya beaucoup de mécènes qui
soutiennent vraiment l'opéra et qui
tiennent beaucoup à ça parce que c'est
leur façon à eux de contribuer et et
chaque année c'est un succès on refuse
d'imaginer combien on peut refuser
d'enfants etc
donc voilà donc ça voilà alors est-ce
que ça aura lieu cette année
si jamais il y avait une nouvelle
réforme des retraites qui repartaient je
pense que
franchement je pense qu'on serait dans
une dune grande difficulté de nouveau
j'en suis persuadé même voilà maintenant
matin je te laisse oui merci sur les
programmes et fait qu'ils n'ont il ya
une partie des spectacles qui ont été
annulés à différentes phases qui seront
repris notamment pour les spectacles
chorégraphiques une bonne partie d'entre
eux une soirée russe qui était envisagé
cette cette saison le rouge et le noir
quelques créations assez attendu devrait
être proposé dans la saison 21 22 et y
compris dans l'espace qui va être rendu
disponible là où devait faire des
travaux l'an prochain en 2021 des
travaux scénique on va les faire cette
année donc ça va libérer notamment
septembre octobre 2021
un peu de temps de jeu il est possible
que le deux productions de la saison 21
soit repris en 21 22 c'est ce à quoi
travaille alexander nef sur le cinéma un
chiffre pour vous pour illustrer
effectivement le propos on a cent mille
spectateurs par an dans les salles de
cinéma dans le dans le monde dont partis
majoritairement en france mais pas
seulement par rapport à 800 900 milles
mais sans 1000cc beaucoup ainsi on le
compare à ce que sont les je crois que
je sais c'est pas très loin d'eux je
crois que les opéras nationaux en région
ont souvent cent cinquante mille
spectateurs dans l'année donc uniquement
par le cinéma on arrive à avoir avoir
cette audience là et c'est extrêmement
extrêmement c'est extrêmement
appréciable sur manon d'ailleurs manon
va être repris aussi en 21 22 ce qui
permettra assez rapidement à ceux qui
ont été frustrés par l'interruption en
cours de jeu dirait deux encourent de 2
séries
ce qu'en disent que quand on était
privés ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on en a pris la décision pour la
quatrième qui est intervenue au moment
où les jauges été réduite de ne pas
accueillir le public pour la pour la
dernière que nous avons joué mais non
moins de la capter pour avoir cette
captation audiovisuelle qui a pu être
proposées un mois et demi après ou trois
semaines plus tard en streaming dans le
cadre de l'offre que nous avons mises en
place pendant la crise et manon à
a été vue par deux cent trente mille
personnes dans la semaine
les semaines de présentation en
streaming ce qui est je dirais
extrêmement intéressant ça ne remplace
encore une fois absolument pas mais ça
devient et spa complément et parfois
parfois un substitut temporaire qui a
qui a eu tous ont tout son intérêt
l'école de danse évidemment on ne retire
rien dans les économies que nous faisons
que le plan économique le mettons en
place pour limiter au maximum les
charges et la sollicitation de
trésorerie de l'opéra l'école de danse
n'est pas affecté c'est vraiment la
préparation de l'avenir et pour le coup
je pense que l'école de l'école de danse
a vraiment un potentiel de développement
de partenariats et compris à
l'international assez important donc il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de réduction de
voilure sur son ambition le nombre
d'enfants qu'elles qu'elles accueillent
effectivement on a une difficulté c'est
que les concours le concours du ballet
n'a pu être organisé pendant pendant
l'été et donc on a ça retarde les
recrutements aux baleines et comme le
ballet lui-même à une activité qui va
reprendre plus tardivement c'est à titre
transitoire à titre transitoire pas pas
une difficulté sur deux sujets
effectivement assez compliqué
l'indemnisation des solistes et puis là
la question des des retraites
l'indemnisation des solistes est
évidemment une question complexe
les solistes sont les chanteurs achats
d'or qu'est ce que nous embauchons
souvent deux trois quatre ans à la danse
qui ont des niveaux de rémunération
souvent un peu un peu hors normes
ce sont des
des contrats dans une très large partie
du monde lyrique à l'échelle
internationale ne sont ne sont pas
honorées ou auxquels la force majeure a
été opposé la situation de force majeure
créé par la crise sanitaire comme étant
un motif de rupture des contrats et 2 et
2 et de non paiement on a essayé de
mettre en place quelque chose
d'équilibré pour à la fois préserver la
relation de confiance entre l'opéra et
ses artistes mais néanmoins tenir compte
du fait qu économiquement on n'a aucune
recette on a évoqué tout à l'heure la
difficulté dans laquelle nous placent la
force de recettes les 40 millions
d'euros de pertes liées à la crise
sanitaire va lesquelles nous allons et
sans rentrer trop dans le détail parce
que beaucoup discussions ne sont pas
achevés sur la période mars à juillet
avec l'annulation de l'ensemble des
spectacles
on a mis en place dès des modalités
d'indemnisation qui sont plutôt
supérieurs à ce qui se passe ailleurs en
europe qui sont assez assez conforme en
pourcentage est plutôt supérieur en
valeur absolue à ce qu'ils sont ce qui
est proposé par la plupart des maisons
d'opéra en france je crois que les
forces musicales avait évoqué une un
taux d'indemnisation entre 20 et 30%
on est en pourcentage danser dans ces
ordres de grandeur et en valeur absolue
sensiblement plus puisque nos artistes
sont sont plus sont plus rémunérés et on
a sur plusieurs dizaines voire plus de
100 artistes concernés on a un très
large taux d'acceptation des
propositions que nous leur avons proposé
quelques artistes les conteste c'est
l'heure c'est leur droit et donc nous
continuons être être en discussions
c'est une question très complexe parce
que il faut encore une fois qu'on soit
attentif
à l'argent du contribuable et ce sont
souvent des niveaux de quand un artiste
a un cachet de ton 10000 euros pour une
soirée qu'il a 12 représentations voit
bien que sur un mois un mois et demi
c'est un niveau de rémunération très
important si une représentation une
série est annulée paraît pas forcément
logique dans l'intérêt de la protection
du contribuable de rémunérer l'ensemble
est en même temps cet artiste il a des
frais il a investi il a attendu cette
rémunération l'annoncé pas facile pour
lui et il faut lui permettre de
conserver son lien avec son art et son
lien avec l'opéra de paris qui sera un
employeur à six mois à un an à 2 ans et
3 ans
tout cet équilibre là qu'on a qu'on a
essayé de maintenir pour le moment on a
un taux de 2 je dirais d'acceptation
presque de satisfaction parce que
beaucoup nous ont exprimé leur
satisfaction
vraiment vraiment assez important et on
s'en réjouit c'est que par rapport à
l'europe à la moyenne européenne on a
été on est on est on est haut au dessus
en plus on a essayé de favoriser avec
martin on a essayé de favoriser aussi
notre façon de rémunérer à essayer de
favoriser aussi les cacher les plus bas
par rapport au cash et les plus hauts de
manière à ce que proportionnellement
donnant le même chiffre à chacun
évidemment si ce chiffre est identique
ce qui est des cachets plus bas ont un
pourcentage plus élevé que ceux qui ont
un cachet plus haut et donc c'était
important aussi pour nous de chercher
façon fait que ça va en gros de 20,3 à
35 plus ou moins 35% pour les plus bas
cachet est plutôt 20 25 pour les pour
les poids lourds les plus hauts du
relais sur les retraites
nous n'avons pas d'information
particulière sur le calendrier l'étendue
de la réforme des retraites qui dont la
reprise est annoncée
ce qui est certain c'est que on avait
commencé nous en janvier puis février à
identifier des modalités identifié avec
les syndicats de l'opéra de paris
des modalités de
traitement par accord collectif au sein
de l'opéra des spécificités qui
aujourd'hui sont traités par une région
spéciale également c'est un coup ce qui
est aujourd'hui un coût qui est intégré
au régime spécial
s'il s'agit d'accompagner des situations
la validité des fins de carrière précoce
pour les raisons j'évoquais tout à
l'heure ça a forcément un coût
même s'il n'est pas démesuré mais c'est
plusieurs millions d'euros par an si ces
spécificités ne sont pas portés par le
régime spécial devront l'être par accord
d'entreprise et dans ces cas là c'est
intégré au modèle économique et aux
modalités de soutien de l'opéra par
l'état 7 le niveau de discussion là on
n'y est pas allé il est malheureusement
aujourd'hui par rapport aux impasses et
aux enjeux auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
du fait de la crise sanitaire
malheureusement il est presque de second
ordre d'un point de vue financier mais
cette taille c'est une vraie question
je pense qu'il ya quand même par
ailleurs une question très particulière
sur les danseurs et leurs carrières
une disposition loi avait été introduite
en première lecture à l'assemblée sur le
texte portant réforme des retraites
permettant d'avoir une disposition
particulière de rupture de contrat de
travail pour les danseurs à un terme
donné à une durée donnée donc en
l'occurrence peut-être 25 ans après le
début de la carrière pour avoir un outil
juridique qui permettent d'interrompre
en toute sécurité pour les danseurs et
pour les employeurs avec des conditions
financières appropriées leur contrat de
travail
faut vraiment savoir que les danseurs
ils sont des sportifs de très haut
niveau on l'a dit je ne rentrerai pas
dans les détails mais pour beaucoup
d'entre eux ils n'ont pas des
rémunérations de très très haut niveau
justement si on les compare alors à
leurs homologues londoniens par exemple
et donc le fait d'avoir cette capacité à
se projeter sur une seconde
une seconde phase de leur vie
professionnelle avec une forme de
matelas de sécurité
ça fait partie de l'attractivité de la
carrière et qui va conduire eux-mêmes ou
leurs parents à les y placer dès l'âge
de 8 9 ou 10 ans lorsqu'il rentre à
l'école de danse lorsqu'il rentre sur un
parcours extraordinairement exigeant et
donc
peut-être que sa peau d'alice dellal et
parlait plus n'est pas n'est pas la plus
adaptée à tous points de vue peut-être
qu'il faudrait trouver des modalités de
reconversion plus ambitieuse mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui elle existe elle et
elle est consubstantielle de
l'engagement de ces artistes dans une
carrière de très haut niveau
donc il faut qu'on arrive à proposer en
substitution si jamais ce système là
doit changer quelque chose qui offre des
garanties au moins équivalentes
et ça c'est un c'est un défi qui sera
relevé à relever dans les prochaines
semaines si le projet de loi dans son
périmètre reprend encore une fois je
n'ai je n'ai pas d'information
particulière
je voudrais juste rajouter un 2 2 points
juste pour votre information une
retraite en moyenne d'annonceurs à 42
ans et autour de 1200 euros par mois et
puis la deuxième chose un peu paradoxal
c'est que j'ai bien peur d'après toutes
les problèmes les projections que nous
avons fait que la le changement de ce
système
remplacé par un autre devrait coûter
aussi cher et ça c'est aussi une
question sur lesquels on devra réfléchir
est-ce que c'est l'entreprise qui
participera à hauteur de temps et et
comment on arrivera à le régler je ne
connais pas la modalité mais le résultat
est la contribution de l'état vous la
connaissez à elle est à peu près de 12
millions d'euros par an 1 en moyenne une
quinzaine vardon alors elle a augmenté
dans les dernières années donc elle est
autour de 15 millions d'euros
elle est votée chaque année voilà
effectivement il faudra payer toute
façon est frappée il ya plus aucun
lanceur qui s'engagera s'il n'a pas eu
une sécurité aujourd'hui de quand il va
s'arrêter d'avoir une retraite c'est une
évidence
même s'il se reconvertit d'ailleurs
sûrement on dit mais ils ont qu à se
reconvertir mais ils peuvent se
reconvertir devancé pas aussi évident
que ça tout le monde n'est pas
chorégraphe tout le monde ne vient pas
maître de ballet c'est pas une évidence
et il faut bien penser que même s'ils
suivent des études à l'école de nanterre
quand ils deviennent danseurs ils ont
ils ont vraiment utiliser tout leur
temps pour devenir danseur ses huit à
dix heures de travail par jour donc
c'est pas évident on jouera à 42 ans de
retrouver comme ça
un nouveau travail pour pour la plupart
donc je pense qu'il faut faut faire
attention pour essayer dé préserver j'ai
juste une petite anecdote ne la
présidente c'est que on peut aussi se
reconvertir autres moins que jean emond
nous avons une très bonne amie qui était
encore de ballet pendant très longtemps
l'époque de sylvie guillem et qui est
aujourd'hui mère d'un petit village du
sud essonne en janvier et vice
présidente et vice présidente du conseil
départemental donc comme quoi voilà donc
on ne peut aussi faire d'autres choses
bien messieurs gattolin oui merci madame
la présidente monsieur le directeur
général monsieur le directeur général
adjoint monsieur le directeur général
vous avez tout au long de votre propos
évoqué une question qui après tout sans
table dans je dirais le monde du
spectacle vivant et son modèle
économique
que ce soit l'opéra de paris que ce soit
des troupes théâtrales aux régionales on
sait que ce modèle économique fonctionne
sur deux bases la billetterie et les
subventions les subventions plutôt
d'état concernant les grandes structures
nationales et subventions territoriales
en gros c'est du 50 50
on voit à travers la crise du
confinement une fois de plus une
réplique de la crise de la billetterie
on l'a connu au moment des attentats
avec les gens qui fuyaient les salles
les surcoûts de sécurité imposé
durablement
on le voit avec aussi les conflits
sociaux
le
le cash des productions on l'a vu avec
la crise sanitaire qui vous amène qui
vous ont amené d'ailleurs à trouver des
modes de diffusion alternatif par la
captation et la télévision et sur ce
premier point
martin a évoqué les accords avec france
télévisions enfin ont à leur tour j'ai
de la comédie française c'est que la
captation qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait
250 mille téléspectateurs
france télévisions a dit c'est pas
intéressant c'est pas une expérience
suffisante alors que c'est autant sinon
plus que tout le public rassemblé en une
année par la comédie française
donc on a un vrai problème
d'articulation gérer entre l'offre
culturelle de qualité et l'audiovisuel
public
dirk hermann on est là on est dans des
logiques purement de captation diffusion
mais les crises et les difficultés sur
le public et donc sur la billetterie
amènera aussi repenser parce qu'il ya
bien sûr le modèle économique mais aussi
le service public qui est assurée alors
vous avez évoqué j'en suis heureux le
carmen de peter brook aux bouffes du
nord que je suis allé voir moult fois
parce que c'est effectivement là on
n'est déjà plus dans directement de du
répertoire classique
on est dans ce que oscar stenberg le
grand spécialiste de la transposition de
la culture dans les médias après une
véritable transposition une réadaptation
et ça suppose nouveau mode de diffusion
appel nouveaux modes de production et
donc nouveaux modes de produits quelle
est la réflexion aujourd'hui et on le
voit on a la même réflexion avec jean
pierre leleux sur la télévision sur les
modèles de financement
les nouveaux produits dérivés qui
peuvent être des preuves produit je
dirais qu'ils ne sont pas en présentiel
qui appelle aussi au delà de la simple
je dirais captation et diffusion
allah en intégrale et c'est important
pour le patrimonial parce que les deux
cent cinquante mille téléspectateurs du
spectacle de la comédie française
on va pouvoir les reproduire pendant 20
ans 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans peut-être même
100 ans sur le marché français donc en
immédiat ça sera pas une ressource mais
on construit aussi quelque chose pour le
patrimoine et pour le public lui même
mais l'idée d'essayer d'inventer de
nouvelles formes médiatiques de
production est ce que ce sont des choses
auxquelles vous réfléchissez parce que
c'est peut-être aussi là qu'on créera
une ressource
j rep alternative mais complémentaires à
celles de la billetterie qui est
fragilisée je parle pas des subventions
quand il s'agit de collectivités locales
qui peuvent connaître beaucoup plus
d'instabilité que celle que connaissent
les subventions d'état
je suis juste de mains serrées pour
développer un des propos de mon collègue
quand il énonce c'est 50-50 subventions
recettes de billetterie en réalité c'est
pas vrai c'est souvent les deux tiers de
subventions à de tiab l'attitude que les
aventures il ya quelques années on prend
oui mais je parle je collectionnais dans
les établissements régionaux
je vous assure qu'on est à plutôt deux
tiers-- et les recettes de billetterie
sont relativement faibles dans
l'ensemble de l'économie de la structure
tout simplement parce que les les
collectivités aussi des politiques
publiques extrêmement volontariste en
matière aussi de tarification qui sont
beaucoup plus modestes
pardonnez moi de le dire c'est moins
cher d'aller à l'opéra en province que
d'aller à à bastille donc j aime à le
dire parce que voilà nous sommes aussi
la société d'assembler des collectivités
il ya un gros effort de fait en matière
de deux subventions et est précisément
ce qui va se profiler la ces des
difficultés aussi budgétaires des
collectivités impact est elle-même par
là la crise et si jusque là n'ont pu
maintenir les subventions et elles sont
volontaristes en général pour le faire
cette histoire de chômage à temps
partiel qui est pas pris en charge
justement dans certains types de
structure va conduire à des difficultés
je ne sais pas si les collectivités
pourront compenser justement
l'ensemble du financement de l'emploi
est juste un petit propos pour
développer aussi ce que dit mon collègue
andré gattolin et je serais intéressé de
connaître votre point de vue martin à
jarry a longtemps siégé comme moi d'un
conseil d'administration de france
télévisions et nous évoquions souvent la
politique de captation du spectacle
vivant il vrai il est vrai que il ya eu
la crise du coc vidé à nouveau une
attention particulière portée à la à la
diffusion et et rediffusion du spectacle
vivant comme offre d'emprunts
substitutive mais offre réelle en
revanche était engagé quand même à un
mouvement de désengagement de france
télévisions je le dis et avait des
problèmes en anticipation du festival
d'aix nous avons une collègue ici se fit
jouer 5 et adjointe à la culture à la
ville d'aix tokyo lequel peut en parler
en connaissance de cause mais il y avait
quand même ce mouvement de désengagement
des captations pour notamment les opéras
donc voilà je n'ai eu à le dire et
peut-être voir comment vous positionner
par rapport à ça enfin je serais
intéressé de savoir merci chers
collègues devoir d une occasion de
compléter et question je vous je vais
vous répondre d'abord juste faire un
petit à petit vous avez parlé de la
comédie-française sept juges pourraient
faire revenir sur le point que j'ai
développé tout à l'heure le financement
de la comédie française il est
majoritairement de avec les fonds
publics
1 c'est la différence avec nous d'accord
donc quand encore une fois quand quand
quand les recettes sont
moindre importance par rapport un budget
global la situation de l'entreprise et
moins délicate
elle est délicate mais elle l'est moins
et si vous regardez pratiquement tous
les établissements à paris ils sont
quasiment tous sauf le louvre
pratiquement je crois que j'aurais
peut-être dans deux autres mais c'est
ailleurs c'est versailles auxerre et sur
les musées mais sinon si vous regardez
l'opéra comique la comédie française etc
sont des établissements qui sont
majoritairement alors je vais répondre à
votre question ce que moi je crois qu'il
faut faire mais c'est une chose assez
assez personnelle et je n'aurai pas
l'occasion de le faire à paris peut-être
je le ferai chez medrano m'a dit
monsieur mais mais mais mais je ne vais
pas le casier de le faire et peut-être
l'opéra pensera différemment de moi pour
le futur alors moi je pense que
la première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'il faut complètement changé le
système audio visuel c'est à dire qu' il
faut que l'opéra le théâtre la comédie
française et l'opéra de paris
ce équipe totalement comme un producteur
était bien que je pense de la première
chose à faire c'est qu'il faut installer
huit à dix caméras téléguidé téléguidés
et non pas avec du personnel parce que
ça prend beaucoup de place d'abord et
puis c'est très gênant pour le public ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut
organiser à l'intérieur de
l'établissement un studio et donc le
théâtre l'établissement devient
producteur si les producteurs il est un
vendeur de sa propre production et en
négocie donc avec le personnel et avec
les artistes des droits et il se
retrouve dans une situation de
producteurs donc de vendeurs c'est à
dire qu'il peut aller voir france
télévisions qui comme vous l'avez dit à
la présidente s'est beaucoup des engagés
lors des dernières années sous la
dernière présidence en tout cas sur le
nombre de spectacles je sais pas il n'y
a pas de critique envers une personne en
particulier mais simplement on est passé
effectivement nous de 6 de
retransmission obligatoire par contrat à
4 + 1 et donc on a perdu
voilà le service public
incontestablement a perdu son a diminué
son engagement vis-à-vis des
institutions plus et c'est pas seulement
nous c'est général donc si vous êtes
producteur la chose qui est intéressante
c'est que bien évidemment vous vous êtes
vous pouvez
non seulement produire vous même et
vendre des spectacles à l'entente vous
pouvez avec le signal vous pouvez
évidemment aller dans les cinémas vous
pouvez aller dans le monde entier
vous pouvez sortir du cadre de la
retransmission c'est ce à quoi je
faisais un petit peu allusion tout à
l'heure et vous pouvez inventer des
nouveaux projets artistiques
c'est à dire que vous pouvez créer des
oeuvres à partir de ce que vous voulez
du répertoire lyrique ou du théâtre etc
alors nous nous avons fait une
expérience avec la troisième scène qui
était très intéressante on a eu quelques
avait écrit un scénario autour de la du
thème de la bohème et nous avons filmé
en direct dans les sous-sols d'ailleurs
de bastille nous avons filmé en direct
pendant 15 minutes 20 minutes un
spectacle à une chose inédite qui
n'avait plus rien à voir avec l'opéra
bien sûr c'était une invention avec un
sujet qui partait de l'idée de la bohème
qui ont été qui aller beaucoup plus loin
et donc on a proposé cinq hommes comme
un objet au fond ce départ d'un opéra ce
n'est pas un film pas une pièce de
théâtre c'est un objet non identifié
aujourd'hui qui mais ça reste dans la
culture lyrique et moi ce que je pense
c'est que il y a on voit bien qu'il ya
un blocage au niveau depuis très
longtemps il ya un blocage au niveau
d'abord de la musique savante par
rapport à la tonalité etc on voit très
bien qu'on est bloqués sur qu'on ne peut
pas espérer aujourd'hui à moins d'avoir
des mises en scène entre guillemets
exceptionnels comme la cu le fer avec
moïse et aaron par exemple de schoenberg
on voit bien que ces musiques là ne
peuvent pas atteindre un immense public
on faisait dans une salle de 2700 places
donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait à côté du
répertoire de 75 ou 80 reprendre le
spectacle qu'offre oeuvre pardon dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
eh bien je pense que nous avons nous les
capacités puisque nous avons le lieu
nous avons le muay et les moyens pour le
faire et nous avons les artistes
pourquoi ne pas inventer et réfléchir
sur un nouveau produit à nouveau produit
j'aime pas ce mot mais j'essaye de
je l'emploie involontairement un pas
d'une preview péjoratif mais c'est de
donner c'est à dire de réfléchir
pourquoi j'ai fait allusion à callao
carmen de petter beau il ya eu plein
d'expérience depuis est à dire qu on se
base
on s'appuie sur le répertoire sur qu'est
ce que c'est aujourd'hui en 2020 les
relations entre une jeune fille et son
père bah c'est gildas et rigoletto
qu'est ce que c'est enfin on peut
imaginer plein de choses c'est quoi la
situation des femmes qui subissent des
violences on peut réfléchir sur des
personnages dans le répertoire lyrique
qui ont la caisse que ces personnels de
loulou qu'est ce que c'est il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut raconter
et qui sont des choses qui nous relient
vraiment à l'actualité qui nous relie au
monde dans lequel nous vivons
c'est ça que j'aimerais faire et c'est
ça que j'aimerais développer avec des
cinéastes avec des metteurs en scène
je ne sais pas encore mais en tout cas
c'est cette idée là que sur lequel je
suis en train de travailler et je pense
que c'est intéressant parce qu'au niveau
européen pour avoir fait un certain
nombre de démarches déjà il ya un
intérêt au niveau de l'europe de
financer ce genre de projet parce que
vraisemblablement influencé par la
pandémie avec tout ce que nous vivons
depuis maintenant trois quatre mois
on voit bien que les politiques et les
responsables culturels réfléchissent à
ça on peut pas venir à chaque fois qu'on
va avoir un problème va simplement faire
du streaming parce que ça va plus
suffire si on veut 4s qui va être payant
streaming oui et non alors que si vous
avez un objet particulier créé pour la
peau pour lé pour la forme digitale pour
pour pour ce bout ce moyen de
communication
vous pouvez imaginer quelque chose
c'était c'est un peu ça que je voulais
dire tout à l'heure mais je j'y crois
beaucoup
j'y crois beaucoup et je pense que on
devra de toute façon mais je pense que
l'opéra de paris fera une sono sais pas
quand mais on sera tous amenés à un
moment donné à réfléchir sur d'être
avoir notre indépendance au niveau de la
production fait toi tu connais ça mieux
que moi d'ailleurs mai
mon nom peut-être une manière on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé des regards aussi
audiovisuel public c'est vrai qu'on a
une impasse n'étaient pas nouvelles
entre le l'ambition d'avoir un public
très large donc d audience de 4 5 10 15
% de part d'audience
le soir sur des chaînes de france
télévisions et ce qu'est le public
potentiel d'une retransmission d'une
oeuvre d'opéra ce qui fait que la
diffusion en direct est quasiment
impossible et que souvent c'est comme on
dit le l'été l'été la nuit que les
oeuvres sont diffusées il se trouve
c'est un rapport de 4 de catherine
clément et quelques années qui qui resté
célèbre qui se trouve néanmoins avec
avec notamment les plateformes
numériques avec culturebox avec arte
concernant relais assez important tout
ce que nous avons fait dans la
l'opération l'opéra chez vous et
l'événementiel isation de captation de
visuels qui ont donné lieu à ces deux
millions et plus de vue on l'a fait
grâce à france télévisions avec france
télévisions avec culturebox ton que je
j'ai parlé effectivement il y avait il
ya quelques années
un objectif qui était respectée ou pas
de 6 captation par an on est passé à
quatre plus un mais ils nous
accompagnent quand même avec un modèle
économique dont on connaît la complexité
je pense qu'il ya là il ya deux ans je
pour l'admirer nains qui est dans des
plateformes de type culturebox ou arte
concert mais peut-être on renvoie on
revient à un autre débat comment donner
plus de visibilité comment avoir un
espace plus évident pour l'ensemble du
public au sein de l'audiovisuel public
qui puisse être le lieu vers lequel se
tournent tous les spectateurs en fait
culture d'oc sarthe et concerts sont
connus de ceux qui les connaissent ne
sont pas forcément si connu que cela au
delà d'un d'un public d'un public
habitué on a une seconde question
d'indépendance et celle de l'équipement
dont stéphane
à parler à l'instant qui consisterait
équiper nos salles de capte de modalités
de captation technique automatisés le
modèle économique n'est pas évident mais
ça peut être un investissement qui
permet de rendre plus systématiques le
la captation dans de bonnes conditions
d'efficacité c'est un un point auquel on
devrait effectivement réfléchir
et puis à l'indépendance en terme de
plateforme aujourd'hui l'opéra de paris
pour diffuser ses spectacles les
diffusent soit à travers culturebox voir
tes concerts soient sûrs d'eux une
chaîne youtube où une une page où une
page facebook ce qui ne place pas dans
les conditions de totale indépendance
par rapport à l'environnement où on se
situe donc on a aussi une réflexion sur
le fait d'avoir notre propre player pour
parler en bon français notre propre
système de diffusion numérique qui
donnerait encore plus d'indépendance
quant à l'environnement dans lequel dans
lequel les captations son sont diffusées
un point que stéphane est évoquée sous
l'angle des delà du dialogue entre
différents univers comment les thèmes de
l'opéra ou lui balaie peuvent raisonner
avec les thèmes d'aujourd'hui il ya
aussi évidemment un travail sur la forme
ça c'est ce que le andré gattolin évoqué
c'est que une captation ça peut être
d'un point de vue patrimonial voir ça
peut être pour un spectateur un accès
formidable à une oeuvre
mais pour toucher un public plus large
il faut aussi trouver des formes plus
courtes plus plus accessible et
attractif qui correspondent aux
différents publics à aux différents
codes et ça c'est en inde est un des
grands enjeux d'avoir des formes
peut-être plus courtes plus accessible
pour pour rendre rendre le monde de
l'opéra plus plus plus accueillants à un
public qui nous qui n'en possèdent pas
forcément tous les codes la plateforme
arias qui a été développée vise aussi à
rendre ces univers plus familier avec
les indes galantes avait été dans le
cadre de la troisième scène fait un
court métrage de 3 4 minutes qui a eu
énormément de succès parce que s'il
était court il reprenait la le volet
danse danse danse urbaine très
expressive qui était
ensuite utilisé par clément cogitore
been toulouse dans les indes galantes
et ça c'était je pense une opération
extrêmement emblématique de du dialogue
entre différents mondes et du fait qu'on
va d'apt en des formes à ce que un
public plus large peut peut que
souhaiter peut espérer on peut on peut
vraiment faire communiquer des mondes
qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas
définitivement fermée ce n'est pas vrai
contrairement à ce qu'on entend souvent
intéressant aussi dans le projet de
dézinguer landes c'est que arte a
enregistré le spectacle dans son entier
est d'habitude corps à arte enregistré
diffuse le spectacle dans son entier est
bien là ils ont décidé de faire 1 1 une
oeuvre qui va durer une heure vingt 1h25
donc c'est intéressant aussi peut-être
que tout d'un coup art et qu'il n'avait
je crois fait la première fois deux
semaines fait à travailler sur le film
en entier mais en faisant un certain
nombre de montage et en proposant donc
bientôt ce qu'on savait le faire à la
fin de l'année le croient ils vont
proposer une retransmission de ce
spectacle mais totalement modifié c'est
oui mais en tout cas ça veut dire que ça
bouge ça bouge dans l'oeuf à bourges le
format est en train de bouger c'est
clair aussi parce que des gens ne
peuvent plus rester ou ne veulent plus
et ne reste plus trois heures ou trois
heures et demie à regarder un spectacle
[Musique]
en réalité dans mon propos liminaire
l'avenir du théâtre eric en général et
aussi quid de quel regard portez-vous
sur la formation en france à la musique
au théâtre à la danse là on a évoqué
mais sur l'école de
l'école de danse mais plus largement
quel quel regard portez-vous judiciaire
[Musique]
cc c'est alors c'est compliqué de
répondre à cette question parce que la
forme de l'opéra comme vous le savez est
une forme particulière puisque nous
venons de parler ensemble pendant deux
heures mais nous avons parlé nous
n'avons pas chanter pour vous exprimer
un nom donc on on est si oui je ne serai
pas à la hauteur mais mais vous pouvez
demander la nouvelle ministre qui a en
tout cas au niveau du répertoire un
champ important
non je crois que la difficulté de
l'opéra qui depuis toujours et le
renouvellement des générations et
d'ailleurs ça envoie ce que je viens de
dire justement c'est à dire
effectivement si nous voulons en creux
compte continuer à conquérir un nouveau
public
il est certain que les formes de l'opéra
devront être sur les nous devons y
réfléchir et la théâtralité a permis du
temps de lieberman qui a été au fond un
moment un passage important dans
l'histoire de l'opéra de paris en 1970
où il a fait venir effectivement des
metteurs en scène du monde du théâtre
qui venait pour la première fois monté
des oeuvres du dieu l'opéra le théâtre
est entré dans le monde de l'opéra et en
entrant dans le monde de l'opéra il a
modifié la perception de ces chanteurs
qu'on mettait devant le public face au
public et tout d'un coup il a créé la
théâtralité et en créant cette
théâtralité il s'est ouvert à tout un
nouveau public
c'est certain il n'empêche que dans le
répertoire de l'opéra vous avez quand
même un certain nombre de 2,2 de
répertoire dans lequel on pourrait
appeler il y a une certaine jubilation
vocale et dans lequel le livret est
assez limité cette forme là d'opéra vous
avez beaucoup de mal à rencontrer le
jeune public
c'est clair parce que ça ne traite pas
le sujet de société ça ne traite pas le
sujet qui attire les nouvelles
générations
sauf ceux qui aiment simplement écouter
les voix et ça c'est très minoritaire et
surtout en france comme je le dis
tout à l'heure et donc comment on arrive
sans entrer dans ce qu'on appelle le riz
j théâtre c'est à dire une théâtralité
qui seraient trop propre qui est très
provocatrices qui est trop radical et
qui fait que là alors on sort on n'est
même pas consciente de convaincre de
nouvelle génération et on est certain de
de perdre l'ancien donc c'est pas non
plus à une voie possible donc sur le
plan de la représentation c'est cette
une c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué parce que la mode le public
changé et la situation de la
représentation aussi a beaucoup changé
le public il est là nous avons nous à
l'opéra de paris depuis maintenant 2
puis hugues gall on va prendre le départ
du gal jusqu'à aujourd'hui une moyenne
entre 800 et 900 mille spectateurs on a
un peu augmenté dans les dernières
années mais enfin que les spectacles
soient est très conservateur ou que les
spectacles soient plutôt moderne on te
rends compte que qu'aux modo on perd un
public on en gagne un dotons faire un
public en a bien d'autres
mais en gros il ya un potentiel de 850
mille personnes à 900 milles spectateurs
qui viennent l'opéra de paris
c'est ça ça va c'est pas donc on voit
bien que au niveau artistique
on est passé de gala gérard mortier ont
cas vers une politique artistique
complètement différente puis on est
passé à nicolas joel avec une politique
qu étant différente de celle de mortier
et puis bon moi je ne peux pas parler de
moi mais enfin donc on voit bien qu'il
ya eu pendant toutes ces années des
allers-retours en matière de conception
artistique parce que c'est là que se
joue qu'est ce qui fait qu'on peut
attirer le public
ja après il ya le problème économique
est le prix des places moi je suis
convaincue mais convaincu et je le
disais avant locaux vides attend gens
retiendront plus envie on ne pourra pas
continuer non seulement augmenter le
prix des places mais on va être
contraint de diminuer le prix des places
je veux juste te dire simplement que
j'ai fait des propositions au conseil
d'administration et que bercy s'est
opposé catégoriquement à des
propositions de groupes de baisse de
prix de place parce que évidemment
l' équilibre budgétaire passait par
parle d'une augmentation sans cesse des
recettes et qu'est ce qu'on a fait
pendant toutes ces années on a doublé le
mécénat on a augmenté les recettes mais
on sait très bien tout le monde autour
de cette table est d'accord pour dire
que 220 240 euros ce cd sont des sommes
énormes et c'est donc réservé à une
toute petite élite qui peut se permettre
se séparent et ça je pense que c'est un
handicap pour l'opéra de paris
un handicap pour le futur et et quand on
pense à cette crise sociale et
économique y est devant nous on peut
imaginer que si on sera complètement
décalé presque on pourrait dire non
c'est presque indécent on a envie de se
dire de proposer des prix de place à un
moment donné où les gens seront sont et
seront en grande difficulté donc ça
c'est le deuxième aspect est ce qu'on
pourra changer le modèle pour pouvoir
avoir des prix de places mais quand je
dis change et prix du talent je pense à
la moitié je pense pas à 10% - je pense
qu'on devrait alors des prix de places
qui devrait tourner autour de 100 110
euros maximum avec des places à 20 25
euros
c'est là le seul espoir qu'on a de
reconquérir un public
d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'on met des
spectacles moins cher on a des
remplissages meilleur donc ça fait un
état c'est un sujet qui qui est aussi
dans le futur si le futur immédiat ça je
pense un bon après je pars et hélas il
ya tellement d'autres choses à dire sur
le sur le sur le fleuve le livre est le
modèle ya beaucoup de choses à dire sur
le situation en europe la situation de
l'opéra en europe comment qu'est ce
qu'on veut pour cet opéra cet opéra il
faut pas l'oublier il est temps il est
en concurrence sérieuse avec les grandes
maisons d'opéra internationale c'est une
c'était vraiment une lutte violente que
qui s'opère entre nous pour avoir les
artistes ils sont pas très nombreux les
très bons artistes les très bons
chanteurs les très bons metteurs en
scène est très bon chef
ils sont très peu nombreux donc cette
guerre à l'oreille ne se joue pas
tellement en termes économiques parce
que dans l'ensemble ce qu'on appelle le
top fi des artistes est assez respecté
plus ou moins partout donc on connaît
donc on est à peu près chacun chaque
théâtre est à peu près la même chose
qu'elle joue pas là ça se joue sur le
projet artistique et si c'est juste le
produit artistique
là il faut attendre de moyens pour faire
de nouvelles productions de ce que vous
avez des chefs d'orchestre les chanteurs
foued faire des nouvelles productions
qui n'ont pas envie de venir faire
justement de rentrer dans une
distribution pour une septième fois
parce qu'on va faire le premier et voilà
donc ça c'est aussi un autre sujet et
c'est la question qui a abordé martin
qui est très importante c'est la
question des moyens pour pouvoir prendre
des risques et pour pouvoir créer une
maison d'opéra elle a besoin de produire
ses propres spectacles parce que ces
ateliers de décors ses ateliers de
costumes ses répétitions avec les
l'ensemble des régisseurs des
machinistes etc tous ces métiers du
théâtre
ils ont besoin de créer ils ne peuvent
pas se satisfaire de reprendre
simplement ou de louer des spectacles
ils ont besoin le choeur de l'opéra
c'est la création c'est le coeur c'est
que moi je suis je suis un salarié et je
participe à la création de l'opéra de
paris pour une
c'est très important d'un point de vue
psychologique au niveau de la motivation
et du désir de l'ensemble des salariés
être protagoniste c'est très très
important
quelles que soient les métiers du
théâtre de l'opéra donc la capacité
future ne peut pas passer par une
diminution
il y aura peut-être des contraintes que
je ne connais pas encore mais cette
question est un vrai sujet et martin l'a
expliqué à travers le risque moi j'irai
au delà du problème du risque je dirais
c'est une nécessité c'est une nécessité
pour une maison d'opéra de créer
je m'arrête est ce que si l'on veut
parler à mes côtés merci pour cette
audition de notre commission et
l'occasion il ya quelques années de cela
donc que l'ensemble des collègues n'ont
pas forcément participé à ce déplacement
mais a eu l'occasion de visiter l'opéra
bastille c'est ses coulisses et arrière
scène c'était absolument passionnant je
crois qu'on aurait peut-être envie d y
revenir martin et organiser ça dès que
voilà la rentrée si les conditions
sanitaires loi la règle en principe ya
pas de n'est pas toi là je suis fort
impact sur les lieux pour comprendre
comment ça ça tout ça fonctionne en tout
cas merci de vous êtes prêté à
l'exercice
nos meilleurs voeux de succès pour vos
futures fonctions et vous serez sans
blessure un attentif à la situation des
opéras l'opéra national les opéras en
france et puis bien sûr
devenu du secteur de la musique danse
étant un peu compliqué nous avons un
groupe de travail très à la pointe
aujourd'hui qui a fait aussi des
propositions que nous avons remis en
main propre
la nouvelle ministre sur ces sujets
voilà je vous rend votre liberté il cher
collègue je vous garde deux minutes
après pour parler plfr ça
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition
menée ce matin par la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication
à présent je vous propose de suivre une
autre audition celle de claire et donc
c'est la candidate proposée par le
président de la république aux fonctions
de défenseur des droits en remplacement
de jacques toubon qui quitte ses
fonctions ce mois-ci claire hédon était
auditionné ce matin par la commission
des lois rial nous commençons cette
séance par l'audition de madame claire
et donc je salue qui est la candidate
pressentie pour prendre la succession de
jacques toubon comme défenseur des
droits vous souvenez que le défenseur
des droits est une institution qui en
2011 a regroupé quatre institutions
le médiateur de la république le
défenseur des enfants la haute autorité
de lutte contre les discriminations et
pour l'égalité qui avait été créée par
jacques chirac et la commission
nationale de déontologie de la sécurité
donc c'est une fonction qui est
extrêmement importante fonction de
contre-pouvoir de soutien aux droits des
personnes et d'une fonction de défense
des libertés avec le nombre de
réclamations auprès du défenseur des
droits a augmenté de près de 40 % en six
ans c'est donc aussi une fonction dont
l'importance dans la république ne cesse
de croître
vous savez que la règle applicable pour
le vote des commissions des lois des
deux assemblées c'est qu'on fait
l'addition des voix des députés des
sénateurs et que la nomination devient
impossible c +23 cinquième d'entre eux
ont émis un vote négatif c'est la règle
des 3 5e négatif donc
le vote aura lieu après l'audition qui
est public qui est ouverte à la presse
madame et dont vous êtes issu du monde
de associatif mais vous avez aussi une
profession vous avez exercé la
profession de journaliste à radio france
puis à radio france internationale et
c'est depuis 1993 que vous vous êtes
engagés dans ce monde associatif avec
l'association agir pour agir tous pour
la dignité c'est à dire atd quart monde
je crois que l'époque c'était madame
geneviève anthonioz de gaulle qui
présidait l'association et à votre tour
vous l'a présidée depuis cinq ans c'est
une fonction qui vous a permis de vous
engager publiquement dans la lutte
contre la pauvreté et les
discriminations
je vais vous donner la parole le
maintenant non sans avoir rappelé
l'importance de cette organisation qui
est atd quart monde qui a joué un grand
rôle y compris dans l'évolution de nos
législations puisque c'est atd quart
monde qui a porté à partir de 1995 le
projet de loi contre l'exclusion et qui
a je me souviens que c'était à la
dernière minute obtenu du président de
la république et du premier ministre de
l'époque
l'inscription dans son article 1er du
droit à la dignité comme matrice
permettant de mieux traiter les
questions de pauvreté que par la simple
redistribution ce qui je crois la marque
de fabrique de votre association
donc madame et dont vous avez la parole
et puis ensuite nous vous poserons un
certain nombre de questions
j'appuie oui c'est bon il faut peut-être
voilà monsieur le président de la
commission mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs bonjour merci donc de me
donner la parole et vraiment je voudrais
commencer en saluant le travail de
jacques toubon et de ses équipes qui
l'entourent il a vraiment renforcé la
notoriété l'identité et le rayonnement
de cette institution à travers des
positions courageuses et et indépendante
il présente la république m'a fait un
grand honneur en proposant la nomination
au poste de défenseur des droits
et je vais vous expliquer comment ces
missions sont véritablement au coeur de
mon engagement depuis depuis de
nombreuses années je vous parlerai donc
d'abord justement de mon parcours et du
lien qui peut se faire avec ce poste de
défenseur des droits puis des priorités
que je pense et doivent être dense dans
cette fonction de défenseur des droits
alors après des études de droit et de
communication et parallèlement mon
métier de journaliste vous vous l'avais
dit je me suis engagé dans le mouvement
atd quart monde comme bénévole il ya 28
ans et je suis présidente de ce
mouvement depuis 2015
et comme vous le savez ce mouvement à la
vocation de mettre fin à l'extrême
pauvreté en cherchant à construire une
société plus juste justement respectant
les droits fondamentaux et légal dignité
de chaque individu
l'objectif vraiment premier c'est de
permettre l'accès de tous aux droits de
tous dans les domaines que sont le
logement l'emploi l'accès aux soins la
culture une éducation de qualité
la vie en famille la justice est en fait
pour les plus démunis pour ceux qui sont
le plus défavorisé dans notre société
cette cette conquête des droits
impliquent souvent un véritable parcours
du combattant
et c'est vraiment en particulier en
voyant ce combat que j'ai pris
conscience des conséquences concrètes
des inégalités dans l'accès au droit et
surtout les injustices qui en découlent
et qui fragilisent la cohésion sociale
de notre société et vous avez fait
référence monsieur le président à
geneviève anthonioz de gaulle et je
voudrais justement la cité parce qu'au
moment du vote de cette loi contre les
exclusions à l'assemblée nationale et le
disait notre démocratie n'existe pas
pleinement puisque elle tolère des
atteintes permanentes aux droits de
l'homme que ces droits sont indivisibles
qui ne peuvent être attribuées par
morceaux et je me vraiment situe dans le
droit fil de cet héritage et je
reviendrai sur cette question
d'indivisibilité des droits alors j'ai
durant mon parcours professionnel aussi
été confronté aux questions d'accès au
droit vous l'avais dit je suis
journaliste je le suis encore
aujourd'hui jusqu'à ce que je
démissionne complètement de mes
fonctions
et dans ma carrière de journaliste
essentiellement radio france
internationale j'ai notamment présenter
une émission sur les migrations et puis
pendant 14 ans une émission sur la santé
et j'ai vraiment été au contact et des
auditeurs et sur le terrain et j'ai eu
l'occasion de constater les questions de
discriminations et de difficultés
d'accès au droit des discriminations qui
sont dues aux origines à l'orientation
sexuelle au handicap aux difficultés
d'accès aux soins de populations
marginalisées et j'ai toujours trouvé
intéressant dans ma vie professionnelle
le parallèle que je pouvais faire entre
ce que je voyais en tant que journaliste
sur les difficultés d'accès au droit est
le combat qu'on pouvait mener atd quart
monde sur cette question d'accès au
droit et j'ai toujours eu l'impression
qu'il y avait un lien entre les deux et
qui avait pas de dichotomie dans la
façon de donges exercer et ma vie
professionnelle et ma vie à côté
donc vous comprenez que ce combat pour
l'accès au droit est vraiment au coeur
de mon de mon engagement est d'ailleurs
ce qui suit à travers moi le savent je
suis déterminée j'ai vraiment une
conviction chevillée au corps selon
laquelle le droit est un levier
fondamental fondamental pour venir à
bout des inégalités et je pense que
cette crise du coc vie de ce confinement
a d'ailleurs mis en lumière ces
inégalités et les a même creusé j'y
reviendrai pour pour vous dire ce que ce
qu'on a pu observer sur le terrain et
dans mon engagement associatif et face à
des situations aux quotidiens as et à la
fois insupportable et inextricables j'ai
vraiment appris à fonctionner en équipe
dans un processus de concertation
d'intelligence collective et cette
expérience elle m'a été utile dans ma
vie professionnelle et je pense qu'elle
sera précieuse dans cette fonction de
défenseur des droits
si vous le décidez comme cela je pense
qu'il faut à des fonctions comme celles
à savoir se mettre à la place de ceux
qui saisissent le défenseur des droits
qui attendent une réponse il faut aller
vers ceux qui n'osent pas ne saisissent
pas le défenseur des droits cette
question d'ailleurs du non recours est
quelque chose d'important
une simplicité aussi qui permet d'être
proche des gens et de gagner la
confiance qui permet de comprendre et de
savoir ce qui dysfonctionne
alors mes priorités évidemment
l'objectif premier du défenseur des
droits et jacques toubon l'avait bien
c'était de mieux servir le citoyen en
partant des attentes des personnes
les services publics et vous le savez
ont besoin de regagner la confiance des
français car les nombreux
dysfonctionnements de fête compromettent
l'accès au droit
c'est entraîne un sentiment d'abandon
d'injustice de découragement
d'incompréhension aussi face à l'absence
de réponse
et tout cela mine la cohésion sociale et
nous avons besoin de cohésion sociale
ceux là où ça entraîne aussi parfois de
la violence envers ceux qui sont chargés
d'appliquer le droit et qui à leur tour
d'ailleurs se sentent menacés ont peur
deviennent suspicieux et on est un peu
dans un cercle infernal et c'est très
largement par le service public est
assurer l'effectivité des droits en
particulier en l'occurrence des droits
sociaux et le défenseur des droits par
la façon dont il répond et dont ils
organisent la médiation et le dialogue
peut contribuer à redonner confiance
concernant les priorités
cette institution doit défendre tous les
droits
et c'est pour ça que je voulais vous
citez geneviève anthonioz de gaulle au
début tous les droits et je mettrai
l'accent sur le fait que ces droits sont
indivisibles et interdépendants tout est
lié car en fait les personnes qui sont
confrontées à des difficultés elles sont
confrontés à plusieurs difficultés
conjointe d'accès au droit est
d'ailleurs le confinement a été
révélateur montrant l'imbrication des
droits et combien la rupture de droits
peut entraîner la perte d'autres et
c'était particulièrement visible sur le
droit au logement qui n'est pas
réellement effectif qui est mise en
danger quand on quand on vit dans des
logements insalubres avec une
suroccupation dans le logement avec du
coup une difficulté avec des pertes de
revenus pour payer le loyer et on sent
bien on comprend bien aussi comment cela
entraîne des difficultés aussi derrière
pour la scolarité des enfants et comment
l'ensemble de ces droits est réellement
un briquet et je je je pense que c'est
important de comprendre cette cette
association qui a entre les différents
droits et en quoi ils sont indivisibles
et que tant qu'on les attaques par
morceaux et quand les mots recel on
n'est pas efficace sur la réalité de
l'accès au droit
ma priorité des priorités va donc être
de travailler sur l'effectivité des
droits de tous les droits
d'ailleurs qu'ils soient économiques
sociaux culturels ou les droits civils
et politiques sans hiérarchie
je souhaite également développer encore
la qualité de la présence et de
l'accessibilité de l'institution sur le
territoire face à la non réponse il faut
rechercher des voies renouvelée du
dialogue et de la médiation avec les
administrations
et puis je souhaiterais également
identifier les sujets sur lesquels
investir en matière d'accès aux biens et
services quotidiens comme le logement
l'éducation l'urbanisme les biens
essentiels comme l'eau l'électricité le
réseau internet et ce confinement nous a
mis en évidence à quel point c'était un
point important aussi pour pouvoir
accéder à ses droits cette question de
connexion au réseau internet et
l'utilisation et sur cette base je
souhaiterais définir les priorités dans
un esprit de concertation avec les
équipes je vais pas vous annoncer
d'emblée un programme figé et à peine
d'ailleurs le registre assez qu'on me
reprochera d'avoir négligé tel ou tel
aspect ou telle ou telle priorité est
d'ailleurs pour les citoyens qui
saisissent le défenseur des droits que
ce soit pour l'accès aux droits après de
longues démarches infructueuses ou parce
qu'ils ont été victimes de
discrimination ou de violences
finalement quels autres priorités que
l'objectif que l'objet de leur saisine
et pour les dons pour dessiner les
perspectives d'avenir je privilégierai
la concertation avec tous les
interlocuteurs en présence que ce soit
les citoyens les services publics les
administrations et j'ai conscience par
exemple que sur les questions de
discriminations qui minent la société
aujourd'hui on est face à de nombreux
clivages à des divisions entre ceux qui
pourtant finalement défendre les mêmes
causes les mêmes principes et les mêmes
valeurs
pour cela il me paraît important aussi
de construire des avis dans lesquelles
certaines des préconisations sont
travaillés avec les administrations
face aux difficultés d'accès au droit
ça me semble indispensable de dialoguer
avec les administrations les organismes
qui sont chargés d'un service public
il faut lever les freins il faut essayer
de comprendre ce qui est possible ce qui
n'est pas pour quoi et vraiment
l'objectif c'est d'être efficace pour
que les droits soient vraiment
respectées
le défenseur des droits est indépendant
je le sais bien mais cette indépendance
nous empêche pas de travailler en bonne
entente sur des objectifs communs avec
l'administration
je vous en avais un exemple sur la
numérisation des démarches
administratives
je pense que c'est à la fois une très
belle avancée mais on sent bien qu'il ya
de grandes difficultés pour des
personnes qui sont exclus des réseaux
internet ou des difficultés avec les
usages d'internet et des ordinateurs et
je pense que les préconisations dans ces
cas là sont à construire avec
l'administration si on veut être
vraiment connecté avec les soucis des
personnes et ceux qui ont travaillé avec
moi le savent je suis déterminé mais je
suis aussi soucieuse d'établir un
dialogue et et d'ailleurs je souhaite
mme entouré d'adjoints solide qui
travailleront dans cet esprit avec une
complémentarité ça nous permettra de
prendre les meilleures décisions
possibles qui sont utiles à l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens
je voudrais vous redire un mot sur
l'impact du coc vie de 19 et du
confinement qui a été révélateur des
inégalités on l'a dit mais révélateur de
l'inefficacité effectivité des droits
pour toute une frange de la population
et d'ailleurs ça met en évidence
certains dysfonctionnements de notre
société
pendant tout ce confinement j'étais à la
fois toujours journaliste à rfi où je
dirige les programmes donc à réorganiser
comment on pouvait continuer à émettre
et puis j'étais quotidiennement en lien
avec les équipes atd quart monde et
entre autres avec les militants car
monde les personnes qui vivent en
situation de précarité et ce confinement
a été très difficile dans des logements
exigus insalubre en suroccupation de
logements la suroccupation c'est à 4
dans 35 mètres carrés si dense que vous
avez 36 m² à quatre on est plus en
suroccupation donc en étant réel sur
occupation dans des quartiers où les
gens avaient pas de résidences
secondaires nantes et donc n'étaient pas
partis donc ils étaient 2 fait plus
nombreux dans la rue ils ont vécu de
façon très difficile la façon dont ils
ont été montrés du doigt comme ne
respectant pas le confinement alors
qu'ils étaient juste plus nombreux et le
sentiment que j'ai eu c'était plutôt que
les gens étaient tout à fait soucieux de
respecter ce confinement
l'inégalité face à l'école les familles
en était très inquiète d'être obligé de
faire du soutien scolaire ne se sentant
pas en capacité avec pas de connexion
internet pas d'ordinateur des
enseignants qui ont eu des idées
absolument formidable pour envoyer les
devoirs lisible sur smartphone en disant
à l'enfant de photographier simplement
ses devoirs
de les envoyer il ya eu de belles
initiatives mais ça a creusé les
inégalités sahamies les parents en
danger et on a été assez stupéfait du
non retour à l'école de ses enfants en
difficulté alors qu'on pensait que
c'était eux qui devait être prioritaire
la version qui a beaucoup été dit s'il
avait peur de la contamination pour
leurs enfants la réalité qui nous a été
dit c'est que on n'a pas réussi à aider
nos enfants ils n'ont pas réussi à
travailler pendant deux mois et demi
l'enseignant va s'en rendre compte et on
va encore nous accuser de pas avoir fait
ce qu'il fallait mais simplement parce
qu'on n'est pas en capacité de les
soutenir la santé plus fragiles les
personnes en situation difficile et plus
victimes du coronavirus des difficultés
à s'alimenter correctement tous tout ça
a mis en évidence aussi des difficultés
d'accès au droit des ruptures ou certes
officiellement il y avait moyen de
continuer à contacter et les organismes
sociaux pour faire valoir ses droits à
la réalité c'est que c'était très
compliqué et qu'il fallait de nouveau
faire des démarches sur internet
voilà je voulais vous redire ce que ce
que j'ai vécu au quotidien comme
difficultés d'accès au droit
et comment cet accès au droit enfin ce
confinement a montré à quel point cet
accès au droit est absolument essentiel
le lot dernier point sur lequel je
voudrais insister et qu'il y ait à ce
qu'on a pu observer pendant ce qu'on
finance c'est le renforcement et le
rayonnement la diversité des délégués
territoriaux
le défenseur des droits est vraiment un
observatoire très fin des difficultés
des personnes au quotidien et ils
doivent d'ailleurs s'appuyer sur ce
réseau pour être une vigie des droits
les vous le savez un les délégués des
territoriaux traite 80 % des demandes
ils ont une vraie connaissance du
terrain ils sont pour la société et ses
dysfonctionnements
et vous l'avez cité l'augmentation de
près de 40% de l'activité en six ans a
montré l'importance de ce réseau
territorial et jeu c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel je veux
m'engager avec ses délégués territoriaux
pour réussir à être encore plus présents
sur le territoire et auprès des
personnes qui ont des difficultés pour
accéder à leurs droits et je pense que
tout un travail a déjà été accompli pour
augmenter le nombre de ses de ses
délégués pour la mise en place aussi de
deux chefs de pôles régionaux et le
dernier point sur lequel je résistais
c'est c'est la question de la protection
des lanceurs d'alert on voit bien qu'il
ya toute la question de la transposition
de la directive européenne et est aussi
des moyens qui doivent être affectés au
défenseur des droits pour vraiment faire
ce travail est transposé cette nouvelle
directive européenne sur les lanceurs
d'alert et pour terminer j'insisterai
sur l'importance du suivi des avis
pourquoi sont-ils suivi ou pas comment
contribuer à ce qu'ils le soient
réellement
je le redis garantir l'accès au droit
est vraiment un moyen de lutter contre
les inégalités de redonner confiance
dans la société
merci merci madame et non vous avez
souligné l'exigence d'indépendance de
l'institution indépendance vous
connaissez comme journaliste et sans
doute aussi comme présidente d'akd et
des quart monde
comment allez vous choisir vos adjoints
je suis sûr que au sein de l'exécutif
on a des idées et il est possible que
vous propose un candidat par exemple
comme adjoint chargé de la défense des
droits des enfants
saurez-vous choisir en toute
indépendance vos adjoints dont vous avez
rappelé qu'ils devaient être des
adjoints solide
oui ça ça j'en suis convaincu il faut
qu'ils aient toute leur place et j'aurai
besoin sans aucun doute de m'appuyer sur
eux écouter pour l'instant mes chansons
d'abord je voulais passer en commission
avant d'avancer sur la question du nom
des adjoints vous imaginez bien qu'il ya
déjà d'abord des gens qui se sont portés
candidats et des noms qui m'ont été
proposées mais de divers endroits et
divers origines et je trouve pour
l'instant en tout cas justement le
pouvoir totalement respectueux et je
n'ai senti pour l'instant aucune
pression très honnêtement et je crois
que vous pouvez avoir confiance dans mon
indépendance pour vraiment les choisir
parce que je pense qu'il ya une façon il
faut qu'on puisse travailler ensemble
donc il faut une véritable relation de
confiance et il faut des profils
complémentaires aux miens et aux autres
adjoints
donc je pour l'instant je n'ai pas de
pression et je compte bien être
indépendante
merci de cette réponse monsieur thani
mohamed soly merci merci monsieur le
président merci madame de de cette
présentation
je suis sénateur de mayotte département
français dans lequel les sujets que vous
vous apprêtez à traiter ont une acuité
particulière n'est pas que mayotte il ya
la grille en hausse il est assez martin
j'ai envie de dire tous les territoires
d'outre-mer mais en particulier ceux que
je viens que je viens de citer
[Musique]
comment comptez vous aborder vos
fonctions dans ces territoires
j'ai eu l'occasion d'interpeller ici
votre prédécesseur monsieur toubon qui
al'occasion de d'éléments d'actualité
relatifs à mon département avaient été
exprimées et expressions à la suite de
laquelle la population locale mme ans
était très ému parce que des choses
méritait d'être d'être précise donc je
l'avait interpellé ici à la commission
des lois et ils devaient se déplacer
dans ce département malheureusement ce
déplacement n'a jamais pu avoir lieu
donc je vous demande
dans le cas où vous seriez vous vous
exercerez ses fonctions comment comptez
vous avec cette institution
abordez vous fonctions dans ses
territoires d'outre-mer très éloignées
et où ces difficultés sont très
prégnante
alors d'abord l'équipe du défenseur des
droits est elle à mayotte il avait sorti
un rapport justement sur les difficultés
d'accès au droit
à mayotte vous imaginez bien qu'avec mon
parcours c'était évidemment un point qui
est pour moi très important cette
question d outre-mer mon parcours aéré
fille m'a sensibilisé à la question
d'aider des pays du sud en l'occurrence
majoritairement de l'afrique et du coup
l'outre-mer évidemment fera partie de
mes priorités ça me semble un point très
important je suis passé à mayotte mais
pas en reportage à mayotte mais aux
comores il n'y a pas il ya 4 5 ans
quelque chose comme ça je bien sûr que
ce sera une deux mais attention bien sûr
qu'il ya une question d'égalité dans
l'accès au droit qui est crucial sur des
situations compliquées
j'ai déjà lu les différents rapports
tarifés par le défenseur des droits
et je compte tout à fait mais appliquée
quand je parlais d'ailleurs des
territoires des délégués territoriaux
je pense est évidemment aussi outre mer
merci monsieur le président en sueur
merci monsieur le président madame nous
avons vu que jacques toubon devenant
défenseur des droits peut illustrer le
fait que l'on pouvait avoir de vie au
moins ce qui est réconfortant voyant
votre parcours je pense que peut-être
cette nouvelle vie sur un
approfondissement de celle d'avant enfin
ne sait jamais mais eux bien sûr un 6
pouces et y est retenu il ya un certain
suspense je vous souhaite bonne chance
je voulais vous poser une seule question
finalement dans notre constitution et
dans nos institutions il y à un
défenseur des droits qui s'appelle ou
une défenseure des droits qui s'appelle
la justice parce que si je considère que
les droits sont bafoués
ben je vais voir le juge
s'il ya une discrimination qui est puni
par le code pénal
je vais voir le juge et finalement je
voulais vous demander quel est à votre
sens la spécificité de la fonction telle
qu'elle est définie par rapport à la
justice
qu'est ce qui relève du défenseur des
droits et qu'est ce qui relève de la
justice pour vous comment ça se passe
pour l'un des remèdes mention très bien
merci beaucoup je pense que cette
question est absolument essentiel on
pourrait dans la façon dont vous le don
vous posez la question penser que
finalement le défenseur des droits ne
serait pas nécessaire puisque la justice
devrait être là un finalement je pense
d'abord que dans on le voit bien le
travail du défenseur des droits il ya
une énorme partie de médiation l'énorme
partie de l'activité et la médiation et
elle me semble d'ailleurs très
importante c'est le premier point le
deuxième c'est quand même une question
de proximité du défenseur des droits de
saisie gratuite du défenseur des droits
de simplicité de proximité qui me paraît
importante et il ya toute une partie du
travail des défenses du défenseur des
droits qui est aussi dans le fait de
faire des propositions et jacques toubon
là beaucoup développé cette partie là
sur le fait que quand il ya des
dysfonctionnements avec l'administration
quand il ya des problèmes de
discrimination finalement ok on traite
une situation mais qu'est ce qu'on en
déduit qu est ce qu on en conclut et
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer
je pense pour moi que c'est
complémentaire que les liens sont
indispensables et qui évidemment ce sera
une des premières choses qu'il faudra
que je fasse cesser d'échanger et de
voir comment on peut effectivement mieux
travailler ensemble mais pour moi ça me
semble complémentaire merci de cette
réponse monsieur collombat bonjour
madame je vous avoue que j'ai été
longtemps très sceptiques quant à
l'utilité de la fonction de défenseur
des droits
d'abord parce que
il ya les droits certes mais plus
important c'est encore les moyens
le droit au logement c'est une
magnifique exemple penser qu'on réglera
ça évitera de construire des logements
que des droits au logement est un peu
farfelue
d'autre part comme l'a souligné donc mon
corps mon collègue notre façon mais je
dirai ce que c'est pas aussi un moyen de
de faire passer les dysfonctionnements
les dysfonctionnements de
l'administration et de la justice mais
je dois avouer que l usage
j'ai changé mon point de vue et est
notamment en constatant ce que vous avez
pu faire face que vos prédécesseurs ont
pu faire et notamment un problème qui
est quand même important est quasiment
oublié enfin passé de côté ses les
problèmes que pose la numérisation de
l'administration et j insiste beaucoup
apprécié notamment ce qui s'est passé au
moment justement où de la généralisation
de la numérisation des cartes grises de
la numéro 11 des des cartes d'identité
enfin et c'est à ma connaissance il ya
que le défenseur des droits qui en a
parlé il ya parlé de ses problèmes qui
étaient vraiment des daevas poèmes qui
empoisonnent qui empoisonne le monde
donc je suis pas je j'ai changé j'ai
changé mon mon point de vue il ya deux
points que je voudrais aborder avec vous
vous êtes vous êtes journaliste qu'en
est il du droit à l'expression
parce que s'il ya un domaine où il n'ya
pas de a pas d'égalité les droits c'est
bien en matière d'expression
il ya des gens que vous entendez tout le
temps des points de vue que vous
entendez tout le temps notre ouvriers
jamais alors est ce que est ce que vous
pensez que puisque vous connaissez bien
le métier il y aurait peut-être pas des
choses à faire et poursuivre un peu le
travail dans cette direction et pour
revenir à des sujets plus mieux connu
la déontologie en matière de homard
matière de maintien de l'ordre de
sécurité je veux dire que il ya eu quand
même en étant un exercice de captation
enfin de disparition du la personne je
n'aurai plus son nom donc elle avait qui
s'occupait justement d en dire des
manquements à la déontologie en matière
de en matière de sécurité
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que y
aurait moyen il y aurait nécessité par
les temps qui courent de se pencher un
peu plus précisément sur cette sueur sur
sur cette question madame est donc des
questions que je voudrais vous poser
merci beaucoup cher collègue madame et
d'eau oui merci beaucoup d'abord sur
cette question du droit d'expression
vous touché un point sensible pour moi
parce que je suis très frappé et sans
vouloir être critique avec mes collègues
journalistes
du côté suiveurs qu'on peut avoir en
tant que journaliste a invité absolument
toujours les mêmes personnes
mais vous savez mais voilà vous avez
touché le point absolument essentiel on
est on est redoutable en radio et en
utilise ce terme
effectivement les bons clients et ça
c'est quelque chose moi d'abord auquel
j'ai réfléchi parce que et c'est la cata
d'écart monde a influencé ma façon de
travailler comme journaliste
j'ai vraiment vu moi j'ai eu un jour un
moment où j'ai interviewé une personne
et au montage n'arrivait rien faire et
j'ai senti que ce jeune avait des choses
à dire je les rappeler je lui ai dit
j'ai un problème technique et on a
refait l'interview et j'ai effectivement
passé du temps donc ça veut dire que
donner la parole à ceux qui l'ont pas
prend plus de temps ça c'est le premier
point et mois après avec mes équipes et
les reporters quand ils me disent eh ben
non les patients il n'avait rien à dire
je disais maintenant enfin il avait
certainement quelque chose à dire mais
quel temps il y as tu passé pour savoir
s'il avait quelque chose à dire ou pas
effectivement c'est plus long au montage
et ça demande un peu plus
d'investissement
et comme les pj sont souvent mal payés
c'est compliqué de développer ce côté-là
ça c'était le premier point le deuxième
sur le fait de pas toujours donner la
parole aux mêmes
j'ai une p dg la france médias monde qui
est très branché sur la question de
l'égalité homme-femme et via le csa on
nous a demandé un jour de calculer le
pourcentage d'invités hommes et
d'inviter femme qu'on avait dans nos
émissions c'était il ya déjà 6 7 ans et
dans une émission santé je pensais que
c'était à peu près équilibré et ben
découverte on a calculé sur un mois 25%
de femmes 75 % d'hommes très vite je
suis allé chercher en me disant mais
finalement les chefs de service à
l'ap-hp dans les hôpitaux publics
quel est le pourcentage d'hommes et de
femmes si j'ai eu un petit peu de mal à
avoir la foi l'ap-hp mais j'ai trouvé
des gens qui me l'ont donné 9 % de
femmes chefs de service à l'ap-hp il y
avait donc un lien effectivement entre
les deux mais il y avait aussi moyens et
j'avais une assistante à l'époque qui
était très intéressé par cette question
il y avait tout à fait moyen aussi de
mieux équilibrer de demander
régulièrement mais finalement est-ce que
vous n'avez pas une femme pour en parler
et très rapidement dans l'année qui a
suivi on est arrivé à un équilibre de 40
à 50 % et est donc mais ça veut dire
juste ce qu'il faut une action
volontaire pour aller chercher des
femmes qu'ils puissent intervenir donc
oui c'est ce droit d'expression me
paraît excessivement important et je
pense qu'on a un problème nous médias à
ne pas être forcément représentatifs de
la société parce que justement on donne
la parole entre guillemets coco bonds
clients ceux qui parlent bien et qu'on
va pas chercher des personnes qui ont
des choses intéressantes à dire donc je
pense que votre question est absolument
essentiel eh ouais allez-y faire il n'y
a pas seulement vous prenez le problème
parole bout assez facile à prendre mais
il ya les problèmes il ya aussi les
oppositions disons de penser d'idéologie
ce qui est beaucoup plus ce qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que vous
savez si vous invitez 50 % d'hommes et
50% de femmes qui diront la qui disent
la même chose on n'avancera pas beaucoup
mais c'est bien pour ça que je vous ai
donné les danses examen
alors voilà donc cesser tout cas c'était
simplement pour vous sensibiliser ou
juin à cela et comme apparemment bon
vous pouvez faire
vous pouvez au moins essayer de faire
avancer les choses
bon vous vouliez compléter votre réponse
mon âme est donc oui j'ai l'heure juste
sur la dde ont dénombré logis sur cette
question là après sur la déontologie des
forces de sécurité c'était effectivement
un point essentiel on voit bien que
c'est un point de crispation
d'incompréhension je pense que c'est un
besoin absolument essentiel sur lequel
il faut travailler
et justement l'adjoint que j'espère
pouvoir choisir ce ces questions doit
avoir une vraie volonté de travailler
ensemble
merci de cette réponse alors une bonne
cliente peut-être madame benbassa oui je
m'arrête pas approprié ce même temps
cordiale sur collègues allez j'espère
merci madame de pour votre exposé
dynamique et intéressant est clair et je
m'en réjouis également de savoir que
vous serez peut-être la future défense
heureux ou défenseuse je sais pas il
faudra qu'on trouve le terme eux
bon d'accord donc c'est déjà mais votre
question de vous laisser pas interrompre
par le président sur qui est associé
charmant vous serez peut-être la
première défenseure heureux et je m'en
réjouis et je joue j'ai travaillé depuis
que j sénatrice avec j'avais travaillé
avec feu monsieur baudis est sûre le
contrôle au faciès et avec monsieur
toubon aussi depuis un moment et vous
avez dans votre exposé parler des
discriminations amplement est ce que
vous pensez aussi continuer dans cette
voie à savoir 1 2 et enfin que la fin je
voulais vous dire que l les
discriminations au faciès les
discriminations au quotidien ne sont pas
seulement au niveau du logement
de l'école et ses hommes il ya une
discrimination
d'ailleurs le dernier rapport que nous
avons reçus de du défenseur des droits
mais l accent largement sur cette
question d'ailleurs c'est dans ce
rapport que le défenseur des droits
elle parle de ses contrôles vingt fois
supérieur enfin le contrôle des
personnes de couleur ou des personnes
issues de l'immigration
23 plus que le contrôle de personnes qui
n'ont pas des spécificités pareil
d'ailleurs c'est pas nouveau puisque
monsieur jobert et rené lévy avait fait
un travail à la gare du nord où ils
donnaient des chiffres à peu près
équivalent mais ceux du défenseur sont
encore plus élevés puisque et dans ce
livre de recherche qui a été fait à la
gare du nord on donnait les les chiffres
suivants 8 fois plus pour les personnes
de couleur noire est six fois plus pour
les personnes issues de l'immigration
des pays et disons des pays arabes
alors qu'est ce que vous vous comptez
faire est ce que vous comptez aller dans
ce sens monsieur baudis avait même
organisé un colloque avec la police
espagnole britannique américaine pour
voir comment on pourrait avancer sur
cette question
et voilà monsieur valls avait proposé
nous nous avions déposé ici un texte
lorsque nous avions un groupe écologiste
un texte en 2011 qui n'a pas été bien
sûr qu'il n'est pas ben qui n'a pas été
présentée aux débats et monsieur valls à
l'époque nous avait promis les fameux
caméra piétons qui marche qui ne mangent
pas qu'ils marchent parfois et c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas en nombre suffisant
voilà je voudrais savoir qu'est ce que
vous vous comptez faire pour ce que
cette question ne soit pas occulter
voilà merci beaucoup cher collègue
madame et dont alors je ne compte pas du
tout occulté cette question elle me
paraît absolument essentiel il faut
avancer dans ce domaine et comme vous le
dites ça fait trop longtemps qu'on fait
ce constat est qu'on n'avance pas
président de la république en a parlé
d'ailleurs hier je pense que c'est vrai
oui je pense que c'est vraiment très
très important d'avancer là dessus oui
oui mais alors après quelle est la
solution moi là je peux pas vous la dire
parce qu'elle doit se faire en
concertation avec les différentes
administrations sur qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire mais je pense que ce point est
essentiel
je suis alerté là dessus très
régulièrement par mes collègues aéré
fille d'origine africaine ou d'origine
antillaise et qui me raconte justement
d'aider des contrôles d'identité que moi
je n'ai jamais eu de ma vie
voilà c'est carrément jamais voilà donc
je vois bien la différence je suis
alerte et là dessus j'espère bien que je
continuerai à être alertés par des
collègues et des amis sur c'est sur ces
questions là je pense qu'il faut avancer
vous donner la solution aujourd'hui moi
je ne l'est pas mais c'est quelque chose
de capital sur lequel est d'ailleurs
enfin je pense que ce que préconisait
jacques toubon sur la création d'un
observatoire des discriminations moi me
paraît important merci beaucoup madame
de la gontrie
merci président bonjour madame pour
prolonger un peu le propos d'esther
benbassa d'abord je ne vous connaissais
pas je ne l'avais jamais rencontré et je
suis très heureuse de voir que pour la
première fois une femme est proposé à ce
poste qui est une une institution est
aussi et n'en déplaise à certains ici
qui pourrait mais je pense à tort ne pas
apprécier cette remarque quelqu'un qui
ne soit pas un haut fonctionnaire et
vous êtes à l'évidence quelqu'un d'
extrêmement déterminés et engagés
et de ce point de vue c'est très
réjouissant
a fortiori lorsque on ne vous
connaissais pas cela étant cela a été
dit jacques toubon a été à ma grande
surprise un excellent défenseur des
droits je dis à ma grande surprise je
les dis dans cette commission donc voilà
je l'avais combattu pendant des années
et j'ai découvert donc voilà il peut
avoir
il pouvait avoir plusieurs vies et donc
sa succession ne sera exigeante mais si
je les box et que j'aurais souhaité que
vous puissiez nous éclairer sur la façon
dont vous concevez votre pouvoir dans le
sens comment allez vous faire pour faire
bouger les choses
je mets de côté l'activité vous avez
raison de le rappeler très importante et
dont on ne parle pas de médiation
qu'en dit je mets de côté c'est que
j'espère que cette activité est efficace
mais je parle de sujets où vous êtes de
fait presque à ranger dans la catégorie
des lanceurs d'alerté et nous avons vu
jacques toubon qui était un activiste de
la défense des droits qui parfois a fait
le choix d'intervention volontaire dans
des procédures judiciaires
et au bout du compte quand est il resté
et ça c'est ma c'est ma préoccupation
essentielle
donc comment pensez vous alors même que
vous pourriez par hypothèse être aussi
activistes je ne sais pas aussi présente
sur le terrain médiatique parce que
c'est aussi comme ça que ça se passe
comment espérez-vous avoir plus
d'influencé pour ça que j'utilise le
terme de pouvoir pour faire bouger les
choses dans les domaines que vous
considérez vous l'avez utilisé à
plusieurs reprises comme absolument
essentiel j'aime bien votre terme de
succession exigeante
je trouve que c'est très vrai mais
justement c'est une chance incroyable de
succéder à jacques toubon parce qu'il a
fait un travail formidable et du coup il
ya une lancée et je pense que c'est une
chance
ça c'était la première chose est la
deuxième vous soulignez évidemment enfin
au moment quand la première fois
l'elysée m'a appelé pour me proposer
enfin me dire qu'il kipré qui pensait à
moi sur ce poste là c'était tout de
suite de me dire mais finalement quoi on
peut être efficace est ce que je me suis
vraiment posé cette question
personnellement est ce que je serai plus
efficace ce à ce poste là où en
continuant à être président de la télé
car demande évidemment pour moi la
question s'est posée dans ces termes là
et donc j'entends bien ce que vous dites
est sur le côté il ya des préconisations
qui sont faites par le défenseur des
droits et puis on a l'impression
qu'elles sont pas suivis je pense que
c'est un peu simple de dire ça parce
qu'il en a qui ont été suivis et je
pense que c'est pour ça que je vous
disais à la fin que je veux faire un
suivi des avis c'est à dire que je pense
que ça me paraît important de lister ce
qui a été suivie d'effet donc est ce qui
est ce qui ne s qui ne l'a pas et
pourquoi et je pense qu'il faut beaucoup
réfléchir aussi au pourquoi
quel est l'endroit où on n'arrive pas à
convaincre les pouvoirs publics de ce
qu'il faut changer à convaincre les
administrations de changer
convaincre l'opinion publique parce que
je pense qu'il ya une énorme partie dans
la question des discriminations qui est
une question vous pourrez utiliser des
termes d'éducation en tout cas de
sensibilisation à ces questions c'est un
point capital sur lequel il faut se
poser mais je trouve qu'il faut aussi se
poser est le bilan de jacques toubon a
aussi montré ce qu'ils avaient avancé et
je pense que c'est aussi important de
s'appuyer sur ce qui a avancé
voilà je voudrais pour madame de la
gontrie préciser une chose c'est que
vous n'êtes pas aux fonctionnaires mais
aucun de vos prédécesseurs de la était
lé médiateur de la république furent
antoine pinay et mes paquets robert
fabre paul le gat jacques pelletier
bernard stasi jean paul delevoye et les
défenseurs des droits furent dominique
baudis et jacques toubon ta vraie
différence c'est que vous n'êtes pas une
femme politique
sssa l'innovation du président de la
république dans la proposition qu'il
qu'il a fait je voulais le préciser
monsieur le comte
oui merci le supposions madame l'a
probablement futur défenseur des droits
jacques toubon a effectivement beaucoup
beaucoup fait sur un certain nombre de
domaines mais je voulais vous demander
si vous conserviez le rôle de la même
manière et si vous considériez que il
fallait il fallait d'abord faire avancer
un certain nombre de sujets dans
l'opinion publique
en accompagnement de la décision
politique ou répondre aux demandes
particulières qui vous sont adressés
avec les moyens que vous avez vous
n'avez pas je pense en particulier à
tout ce qui est la médiation préalable
obligatoire qui a été testé avec un
certain nombre de succès par le
défenseur de droits depuis quelques
années mais aussi les difficultés pour
des situations individuelles à faire
valoir la position que vous pouvez
prendre à la suite d'une instruction est
ce que ce suivi des dossiers individuels
est une priorité absolue
ou est ce que sait faire évoluer
j'allais dire l'opinion l'action
publique sur un ensemble de sujets comme
celui qui a été évoqué et qui est majeur
de la déontologie de 2,2 des forces de
des forces de police en particulier qui
qui qui suscite énormément de débats et
puis puisque vous avez évoqué le sujet
j'aurais pas évoqué sinon vous avez
parlé des pigistes
est ce que vous considérez vraiment que
dans la situation dans laquelle
l'information est fait aujourd'hui la
dignité et la situation des pigistes
permet une information complète et
qu'ils soient pas normaliser la dei
madame et d'eau est ce que je peux vous
répondre
l'information je reviendrai après dessus
mais sur ce que vous dites pour moi
c'est tout ensemble et quand je vous
parlais d'indivisibilité des droits
c'est bien ça que je faisais référence
aussi c'est à dire que je pense que
c'est indispensable de continuer à
répondre aux demandes individuelles
autrement la confiance ne sera plus là
et autrement il ya une notoriété a
largement augmenté du défenseur des
droits
mais il faut encore qu'on progresse il
ya encore trop
autre personne qui pourrait le saisir
qu'il ne le saisisse pas parce que parce
que pensant pas que c'était possible
pour eux donc je pense que cette partie
là de répondre à chaque demande
individuelle me paraît absolument
capital mais évidemment qu'en parallèle
il faut faire bouger l'opinion publique
et moi je dirais il faut faire bouger
aussi des pouvoirs publics je mettrai
les trois se absolument sur le même
niveau et je ne pense pas qu'il faille
hiérarchisée je pense que du coup c'est
difficile parce que j'ai bien compris
qu'ils avaient un problème de moyens
l'augmentation de 40% de l'activité en
six ans les moyens n'ont pas augmenté de
40 % derrière donc j'ai bien conscience
de ça et c'est quelque chose auquel je
voudrais m'atteler très rapidement mais
je pense que c'est très important de
répondre à ces trois points en même
temps et après ça sur l'information
j'ai été pigiste pendant des années je
n'ai eu un cdi à france médias monde qui
lie à 13 ou 14 ans quelque chose comme
ça donc j'ai passé une grosse partie de
ma vie professionnelle avec des contrats
de griller à la pige
je pense que oui on laisse ces personnes
trop en insécurité trop longtemps
je pense qu'il ya un problème de moyens
financiers aussi lié à ça mais je pense
que c'est ont je pense qu'on ne traite
pas toujours bien aux pigistes j'espère
moi les avoir bien traité il faudrait
leur demander mais j'ai été vraiment
soucieuse de défendre leurs intérêts et
leur travail parce que c'est absolument
capital merci de cette réponse madame
marie mercier ce président là madame
vous avez un parcours tout à fait
intéressant on voit que vous n'êtes plus
dans l'investigation que dans
l'information vous êtes une femme de
terrain avec une volonté d'agir ça
transparaît dans vos propos je crains
cependant que comme tout vous semble et
est important il ne faille tout de même
donné des priorités à tous que vous avez
décliné devant nous je mettrais un petit
bémol sur la crise du coc vide qui a
effectivement montré des
dysfonctionnements et dans votre exemple
il est un peu tristounet sachez que dans
nos communes nous avons par le biais des
ccas eu un suivi de nos familles en
grande difficulté est que nous sommes là
aussi proche du terrain avec la
proximité nous sommes là pour les
écouter et
ne pas arriver aux extrémités que vous
avez décrite madame alors en ce qui
concerne le travail que moi j'ai mené
ici au sénat avec mes collègues sur
plutôt les mineurs et les violences
faites aux mineurs nous avons travaillé
effectivement que le défenseur des
droits
et je voulais savoir quelle serait votre
appui en particulier dans la lutte
contre l'exposition des mineurs aux
films pornographiques destiné aux
majeurs quel serait votre appui à côté
des associations qui souhaitent qu'ils
sont aussi dans la défense des enfants
comment vous voyez cette articulation
serez vous un partenaire
serez vous quelqu'un qui va aider les
parlementaires
quel qu'il soit parce que vous n'êtes
effectivement pas une femme entre
guillemets politique mais vous êtes une
femme d'action dont on attend à ce que
nous fassiez bas que vous nous fassiez
rêver aussi en disant que vous allez
prendre les choses un peu autrement
peut-être et faire en sorte que bien
toutes ces causes tout c'est qu'on
avance
et puis je pense qu on vous appellera
madame deux défenseurs en la défenseure
la défense andalouse la défend la
défenderesse que je pense qu'il faudrait
demander mais je pense que c'est plutôt
madame la défenseure enfin moi c'est
plutôt là dessus la défenseuse je me
sentais pas très à l'aise avec ça
quelle affaire la défense vous avez
raison ce que la rapporteuse c'est pas
bien notre situation d' importantes à
leurs frais pour nous de traiter cette
grave question pour aborder ensuite
selon les images d'abord madame vous
avez raison de rappeler qu'à des
communes qui ont fait un travail
formidable et quand je parle j'ai c'est
pour ça que j'avais donné l'exemple
aussi d'enseignants il ya eu des
exemples de solidarité d'action de
communes et de mère absolument
extraordinaire et c'est vrai que c'est
bien de le dire parce que aussi ça
montre que c'est possible
et parce qu'autrement on al'impression
ben voilà d'un tonneau sans fin et qu'on
n'y arrivera pas or il avait des moyens
d'agir et des vraiment d'agir bien donc
c'est bien de le dire
vous imaginez bien que lille sud atd
quart monde on a beaucoup travaillé sur
la question du droit des enfants donc
pour moi c'est une question absolument
primordiale qui doit d'être km
travailler avec les avec les
associations qui sont sur le terrain qui
ont déjà des idées sur ce qu'il faut
faire et comment faire je pense qu'il
faut progresser je suis persuadé que les
personnes veulent bien faire c'est à
dire je pense que dans l'aide sociale à
l'enfance par exemple les personnes
veulent bien faire
par contre on sent bien qu'il ya encore
de grosses difficultés il ya encore des
situations de violence faite aux enfants
il ya encore des déficits
d'accompagnement des familles on parlait
tout à l'heure du droit au logement mais
mais comment élever des enfants
correctement quand on est à quatre dans
une chambre de bonne
je pense aussi que la question du
logement est pour moi très liée à celle
de la question de la protection des
enfants et surtout toute la question de
la pornographie est toute la question de
juste aussi de l'accès internet de
l'utilisation de de la protection aussi
avec ce qui peut se passer sur les
réseaux sociaux
ce sont des points très importants qui
concernent absolument tout le monde et
qui doivent être qu'ils doivent être
creusés et là je pense qu'il ya aussi
des idées pas simplement issus du monde
associatif justement issue aussi des
politiques des élus et je suis convaincu
du travail que le défenseur des droits
doit faire avec
avec le parlement sur ces questions là
merci beaucoup madame et dont c'était la
dernière question est donc nous allons
vous libérer et procéder au vote dans
votre absence
je sens avant le voilà et je crois que
vous avez de l'audition de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale ce
matin aux six jours maximum
très bon au casino merci beaucoup et
j'espère vraiment voilà vous avez pu
suivre l'audition de claire et donc par
la commission des lois du sénat claire
et dont c'est la candidate proposée par
le président de la république aux
fonctions de défenseur des droits en
remplacement de jacques toubon qui
quitte ses fonctions ce mois ci je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver toute
l'actualité parlementaire sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr et je vous
souhaite une excellente journée à tous
[Musique]